so Dave Rubin got suspended after Jordan
Peterson got suspended and Dave Rubin
got suspended on Twitter for tweeting
that Jordan Peterson got suspended we
are in the silliest version of the
censorship nightmare dystopia but I mean
it it is bad that uh they took this old
tweet I say old like a week and a half
old and then this morning I get an I get
hit by Dave and he's like yo they
suspended me for this and then I see
that actually he was just like hey he
has a tweet where he's like Jordan
Peterson got suspended and they said
that broke the rules so Tim guest
reached out to Twitter for comment and
Twitter said his tweet violated the
rules on hateful conduct here's where it
gets crazier the Tweet was about actor
Elliot page formerly known as Ellen Page
for those that are not familiar
Ellen Page as a phrase was trending on
Twitter for 45 minutes BuzzFeed flipped
out reached out to Twitter and said how
could you break your own rules so
Twitter deleted the trend we are in you
know it's not quite Fahrenheit 451 or
Brave New World or 1984 it's something
much stupider hey but at least Rod talk
talk about it on the show so we'll talk
about that and then in the vein of
censorship it's funny Crosby Stills Nash
and Young remember when they were like
we're taking all of our music off
Spotify because Joe Rogan's a bigot well
all their music's back on Spotify shows
how far their convictions went I'm
telling you guys if you stand up speak
out speak out for what you believe in
you'll win these people they're they're
just they're just chasing after money
they take their money offline or or I'm
sorry they take their music offline
because they want cash and they think
it's going to benefit them when it
doesn't they come crawling back so we'll
talk about that and then speaking of Joe
Rogan he called Joe Biden a dead man
in reference to I guess Joe Biden not
being all that functional and Donald
Trump running against him in 2024 and
winning so we'll get into all that stuff
we've got a ton of news today a lot of
censorship-based stuff so we'll talk all
about that uh before we get started head
over to timcast.com and become a member
to help support our work as a member
you'll get access to exclusive segments
from the timcast IRL podcast we're going
to have one of those up for you tonight
at 11 PM you'll be supporting our
journalists and we're we're actually
working behind the scenes on
documentaries we're going to be working
on a bunch of new shows that are going
to be behind the paywall the idea is to
just start making as much content as
possible for everybody who's members and
make it really really worth your while
to be a member and just uh use the
resources we get from our members to do
cool stuff journalism movies Etc and uh
maybe one day we'll be as cool as the
guys over at the daily wire
but for the time being you can smash the
like button subscribe to this channel
share the show with your friends joining
us today is Elita majeka AKA legal bites
got it right all right how's it going
good how are you I'm great who are you
um I'm I'm doing all right well who who
are you who am I
um I am a lawyer I run the channel legal
bytes on YouTube
um and
um yeah that's that's who I am all right
so we'll talk about the law we were we
were arguing over Alec Baldwin before
the show maybe that'll come up too
because I'm like he did it and I'm
banging on the table guilty
uh we also have Mary Morgan hi I'm Mary
I'm the co-host of Pop Culture crisis
and I'll be Shilling for it all night
that's right uh because we lost our
resident Catholic Sheamus we just had to
pull in Mary here I am there you go and
then we got you hi everyone Ian
Crossland here of uh Tim cast IRL coming
at you live what's up
Lydia's out sick I don't know if Chris
wants to say what's up
who are you Chris I'm I guess he's Chris
give me more I like it yeah he's he's
filling in I want more that's it I guess
all right let's jump to this first story
we had this from the post millennial
breaking Dave Rubin suspended from
Twitter after defending Jordan Peterson
Reuben offered a defense of Jordan
Peterson after he was suspended for
tweeting about actor Elliot page using
that actor's name prior to Paige
undergoing gender transition
so uh I think that's the real issue that
got him suspended so Dave let me just
pull up the actual tweet here
so this is a tweet from Jack besobic uh
Reuben report has been suspended from
Twitter for defending Jordan Peterson
Reuben tweeted on June 29th the insanity
continues at Twitter Jordan B Peterson
has been suspended for this tweet about
Ellen Page he just told me he will never
delete the Tweet paging Elon Musk
that was hateful conduct that that tweet
he issued a statement sang I have been
suspended by Twitter for posting a
screenshot of Jordan Peterson's tweet
which got him got he himself suspended
while it's unclear how I broke their
terms of service it is clear that they
are breaking their fiduciary
responsibility to their shareholders by
letting a bunch of woke activists run
the company I hope Elon musk's purchase
of Twitter goes through so he can blow
up their servers and Humanity can move
past this pervasive Twisted self-imposed
mental institution in the meantime you
can find me at reubenreport.locals.com
the platform I created to fight big Tech
censorship something we need now more
than ever it's truly amazing I mean this
is the the the insanity of the world
we're living in but this is where it
gets crazier
let me jump to this uh let me I think I
have this tweet here BuzzFeed news said
Elliot Page's dead name appeared as a
trending topic on Twitter violating the
site's own policy on hateful conduct in
a statement to BuzzFeed news a Twitter
spokesperson said it was a mistake and
has since been removed okay
that's it
I understand I think some social
networks have the the term that if you
reference a tweet or reference a post
that had gotten someone banned that that
reference is also bannable offense and
this is to get people to stop people
from retweeting things that had gotten
banned because then you're just kind of
getting around the band it's reporting
just factually on what happened I think
that's all that Dave Rubin said but he
said Ellen Page
you can't even acknowledge that Elliott
page used to be known as Ellen Page no
you certainly can but there are
Americans so arbitrary right you can
they'll just span you or suspend this is
like the most heavy-handed nonsensical
over Administration I've seen from
Twitter in a long time let them do it
the more they do stupid ish like this
the more regular people are gonna be
like what yeah dude Peterson's off the
platform Jordan Peterson Now Dave
rubin's leaving like I I never used
Twitter from 2008 to 2020 because I
thought it was insane and redundant like
I already have Facebook as my text
platform I like the hashtag system but
it's just old Tech like what people you
know anymore yeah it's I mean it is it
is a little scary to see that as someone
who is just referencing something else
happening someone else getting getting
taken off the platform and talking about
it around the context can also be then
taken off the platform itself as well
it's that that is very alarming I will
say that from looking at Dave rubin's
initial tweet about it did look like I
mean you can look at it from maybe I'm
just playing devil's advocate here but
like you know he did say he did
reference her or her reference Elliott
Pages Ellen Page
um without any context of like you know
like saying that you know the artist
formerly known as as Ellen Page or
something like that you know what I mean
is that okay is that allowed I don't
know that's still compelled yeah over
the weekend I was talking to a
five-year-old and I was he was like hey
stop calling me dude or man just do it
once a day and then call me by my name
the rest of time I was like well there's
this thing called compelled speech and
he was like what is that and I was like
oh that five-year-old here we go okay in
the United States you can ask people to
say whatever but you can't make them say
whatever we have free speech
he asked me to call him by his name and
I was like well there's a thing called
conspelled compelled speech where you
can't make me say things so I can I'm
allowed to call you what I want to call
you you should have been like for that
I'm calling you Dingus the conversation
got derailed before I really was able to
like you know illustrate the law
five-year-olds usually are it's
important yeah it's important okay then
guess I won't call you Dude anymore
there's this like desire even of
children to control Reality by making
people do what they want play the game I
want it to be played call me the name I
want to be called and like you're seeing
adults do it now it's really ridiculous
are they adults I think that you think
you hit the nail on how the hammer these
people are children I mean look at look
there's a subreddit called adulting you
ever see this no you know what I'm
talking about Mary just adults
complaining about having to do normal
adult yeah they're like I had to pay
bills today and they're a lot there was
one it's crazy that was a viral post
about adulting and it's like 35 year old
Millennial dudes being like Oh I had to
walk my dog today adulting it's like
okay but there was one post and it was
just like someone doing it was like it
went viral and was talking about their
frustrations with everything wrong with
the world like why do we have to live
this way like why am I dealing with
these things and it's like I get it I
get it you never grew up you never want
to grow up you have Peter Pan syndrome
whatever it's called you want to just go
off to Never Never Land you want to hide
under the covers fine but stop voting if
you don't want to be in charge don't be
in charge you're making everything worse
if this goes to the tribal lifestyle
like what we used to have were like a
weak person would would threaten the
tribe's existence if someone was
severely overweight or or just lazy or
drugged out all the time you you become
a risk for the tribe the tribe is going
to deal with you well here's here's the
thing you were mentioning like like Dave
did say Ellen Page I don't think Dave
understands why he wasn't allowed to do
that I think he was just like like he
sees Jordan Peterson's tweet he goes
whoa look what he said about Ellen Page
and they're like ah you got the name
wrong like how is the the Assumption
here is that every single person knows
about the personal life of Elliot page
yeah that's crazy and to be fair people
have known about Ellen Page much longer
than they've known about Elliot page so
I mean you know someone could he could
very well have made a just a very honest
legitimate mistake to say I I thought I
was referring to the right individual I
don't I don't think Dave thought twice
about it yeah I think Dave was just like
I can't believe this happened and just
did a quick tweet and that's it it's
like oh you've offended the woke police
the crazy thing about this though is how
uh BuzzFeed complained to Twitter and
Twitter took a viral Trend down for real
yeah so can I just say my name's not Tim
anymore it's Tom and then all the Tim
pool Trends just have to be deleted
confusing everybody
technically I guess you could get
illegally changed not even you should
did did Elliot page legally change their
name
probably I don't know I don't make
assumptions tons of people who change
their names just change it they don't go
to the courthouse and get it legally
done some people just be like my new
name is you know whatever Prince or it
became a symbol I guess yeah I heard
that was for legal reasons though
I don't know that specifically but I do
remember that I mean the reason why they
said the artist formerly known as Prince
is because they were like we need
something to be able to sign legal
documents yeah you can't just put a
symbol down like you can't do that you
need to have some kind of a legal name
so that's why they would they would
refer to him as is that under the law
though like you have to have a verbal
name yeah
uh that I I think I think also that's
also why
um Elon Musk said that they changed
originally what they wanted their son's
name to be him and Grimes yeah um
whatever whatever they said they'd like
yeah but it's like they narrow they
narrowed it down to Ash or something
like that but like so originally he
wanted like all kinds of different
symbols and things that are not in the
English alphabet and so I guess the US
government was like you can't do that
what ultimately there's going to be a
name that you verbally call a child I
mean so yeah what was that going to be
yeah there there has to be there has to
be something it's like ash Archangel but
okay something like that does it have to
be a like
Germanic vernacular it has to be the
English alphabet it has to be the
English so you could theoretically go
like
right aww oh wow
yeah good luck saying that just if you
say it wrong I'll get you one syllable
wrong it's over for you and then
actually my my given name was
and I've changed it
and so if you get it wrong that's dead
naming I mean that's pretty true I can
tell you as someone with a not very
common first name that that um that
would be a murderous name to grow up
with well yeah like I remember I was
talking I I was mentioning your uh issue
with um it was when when Washington Post
came after you it's so insane and I
think I said a light Elite I have no
idea oh yeah that's right
what am I going to get banned because I
couldn't pronounce someone's name of
course you are officially henceforth
band what was the wapo situation oh that
was Taylor Lorenz
um how she wrote an article about the
the supposed influencers that really won
from the depth the herd trial so she
called you radicalized in one of her
subsequent tweets yeah she she said she
called she said well to be fair she
referred generally to radicalized
influencers and I don't know if she was
referring to me and that umbrella guy or
if she was referring to other
influencers that were commenting on the
whole situation in in the the series of
of of errors that were not corrected
um or if it was like all of us all
together but it is a funny thing all
right so here's the the gist of the
story is
you're you're Elite you do legal
commentary yeah you were commenting on
the biggest you know pop culture or one
of the biggest court cases in in the
country yeah and so she wrote this hit
piece as though you were a grifter just
trying to get money or whatever and I'm
like it's a lawyer talking about pop
culture you don't get more mainstream
than that yeah and then what happens is
she she writes fake news about you and
then you call her out other people got
mad yeah that she's she wrote fake news
so she's like you're all radicalized if
if you if you dare correct me you're all
radicalized that that's if that's the
ideology
anti-tailed herense she was kind of like
Amber heardstan uh no she's out Amber
Heard wrote for the Washington Post
but the point is the article was
published Kayla Lorenz works for wapo
yeah so of course there's a major
conflict of interest yeah yeah there is
they were thinking about taking that
down
but I think they just added a note I
don't I don't recall if they actually
ended up adding a note to it but my my
assumption was that they were never
going to take that down unless they were
actually compelled to do so
dude Taylor Lorenz has like been having
major meltdowns like her or she's losing
it yeah it reminds me of like an abused
dog when it's more likely to snap out
and lash out at people coming up to pet
it like if an animal's been abused it's
more likely to attack someone that comes
near it usually for the most part who
did anything to Taylor friends who knows
what her childhood was like but for her
to see danger
bro yeah so but a lot of rich people are
twisted when they're kids like bad
parents it's not just that it's at their
their snowplow parents clear out all
obstacles so they never actually
experience any hardship so then they get
older I feel the lightest snowflake
touches their skin and they scream I
don't want ill for or anything but for
her to be seeing radicalization all
around her is like and yeah there is
radicalization going on reality this
fifth dimensional Warfare weird you know
twisting but it's you know obviously if
you see it all around you then you got
to look within because it's your own
lens that you're seeing reality through
that's it's making it look a certain
color I saw this viral tweet I didn't
fact jack it so fact check me on this
one but uh someone tweeted Taylor Lorenz
actually I think it was Viva so I trust
it uh that she was like people are
getting sick at VidCon with covet
because VidCon literally did nothing to
mitigate uh kovid and then he also
posted a tweet from VidCon where it's
like you know vaccine and negative tests
and masks are required or something like
that I I maybe not masked but it was
like you know you need a negative test
within three days to come to the event
so Taylor Lorenz is literally just
making stuff up yeah now look I don't
care about this woman but the issue is
she is wielding The Washington Post like
you know what was that what was the name
of the sword that he man had whatever
that one she's wielding it like I don't
know if it had a name that's awesome
that's sort of gray school or something
was it yeah I don't know she's holding
up the Washington post and using it to
to smack people around and cause damage
to other people that's the problem
yeah I mean and the Power sword it's
called the power Power sword no I was
going to say that I mean the issue that
that that I had with with my my run-in
and and with tugs run in with her was
that it was it was just it was it was
something that really shouldn't have
been an issue it should have been just a
very simple correction to say like okay
we're correcting it where I said that I
reached out to them for comment and no I
didn't reach out to them for comment
until after we had published but they
had several Corrections on there where
ultimately they uh it said that
um the the final like resting place of
this like laundry list of Corrections
was that
um it said that that she had not reached
out to
um tug at all beforehand
um but she had reached out to me by
Instagram which is literally the last
place that she reached out to me but
after Twitter DM which was after I
called her out on Twitter this is the
crazy thing they play this game where
they'll be like we reached out to Ian
for comment he did not respond and then
like what does that mean it turns out
they sent a letter in the mail yeah to
an old address to an old address yeah
smoke signal like we did legally for for
a legal purpose he held his name out
into the woods but there was no response
yeah yeah it'd be funny if there was and
then he got back to me they didn't it
didn't even if I remember correctly I
didn't even say that we had to that we
had not responded to comment but that we
had declined or that that we we had we
had essentially refused to comment yeah
but that would require a response from
us maybe instead of reach saying we
reached out they should start saying
they received our request for comment
and did not because reaching out is
different than yeah it doesn't even if
you reach out for comment in the middle
of a of a forest and yeah in the middle
don't be surprised when you don't hear
back yeah but that's the game they play
yeah
but they they do this thing where
they'll like send a general inquiry to
your like info line on your website
which is you know like a low level
levels like so you know Joe Rogan never
responded you know because they like
went to his website and submitted a form
to his booking manager who did in the
trash and didn't know what it was to
info Joe rogan.com yeah things like that
they will or they'll like look your name
up in the phone book and they'll call it
and be like they didn't comment you're
like bro there's a bunch of people with
the same name as me who are you looking
up it should say that we were unable to
contact we're unable to get in touch
with someone for contact but that's also
just not true because you have to try or
we did not that'd be a better way we did
not get in touch with them for comment
yeah I I what they what they do with
these comments is they're trying to
feign credibility that's the whole point
and they want you to seem less credible
so they'll be like oh they never got
back to us that's their fault but here's
here's the thing even if you get back to
them they're gonna twist whatever you
say yeah they're gonna mangle it up you
know you're gonna say something like uh
look I'm a legal YouTuber I'm commenting
on a very publicly you know public trial
and I'm taking my my expert opinion uh
for what it is and then they'll write
when they responded they expressed that
it's a very popular trial and it's good
for business
and then when you're like I didn't say
they're like well that's how we assumed
it to be yeah and then what are you
gonna do or something along the lines of
like this is yet another lawyer
profiting off of poor people and their
misery so should you send a video
response as your comment and then put
the video response online later when
you're like this is where they got the
comment from so so or just a public
tweet but but it is better to do a
public tweet because everyone can read
it but they will write whatever they
want sure right so I'll tell you this
Ian how do you feel about
um Bakery fresh cinnamon buns well I'm
not down with the carbs but you know it
smells good when asked for comment on
Bakery fresh cinnamon buns Ian let out a
displeasing grunt
seemingly showing dissatisfaction
commenting not pleased dot dot dot he
even wanted to say that there were
problems with them he said I'm not into
dot dot dot the smell
exactly and then people are gonna but
imagine that from uh so so that's
actually a good example because people
are going to be like what sane person
does not like the smell of Bakery fresh
cinnamon of course
right now imagine though it's something
very similar to that but like political
violence or January 6th or something and
you'll say something like obviously no
one's going to come out and say I
support all of this violence and they're
going to be like he responded with data
dot quote I support all of this I had
this thought over the weekend that
whoever controlled in the past whoever
controlled the newspapers controlled
politics like you could write whatever
you wanted and twist the entire world
and now it's just that with social media
like Twitter took down a hashtag of a
trending that's not how trending Works
trending that is what's trending yeah
it's really funny the reason they did it
too somebody was like I don't like that
name stop letting people talk about it
at some point I think people will be fed
up with private corporations controlling
politics
well let's let's talk about a bit about
that we have this story from people
Crosby Stills Nash and uh not Neil Young
I know Crosby Stills and Nash music is
back on Spotify months after Joe Rogan
boycott so the big story was that uh you
know Joe Rogan this compilation went
viral and everyone was calling Joe Rogan
racist and all that he apologized for it
but uh all of these people were like I'm
taking my music off of spotify and uh
Crosby's still in Nash as well as Neil
Young they did they're back that's it
they're back actually Neil Young I guess
half his music stayed on because he
didn't own it anyway that was actually
really funny but this is really
important it shows you the depth of
their of their values
none shallow not even an inch deep they
did this because it was Major press let
me tell you guys
when I was uh doing the Occupy Wall
Street stuff I had all of these
companies hitting me up being like we
want to give you all these things we
want to you know hire you and I'm like
yeah yeah something happened in the
Press you want to put out your press
release and be like this guy's with us
now so you can get free press off of
somebody else not interested that's all
they did these guys were they probably
had a manager who was like guys guys
now's your chance it's big in the news
it's Joe Rogan he's the biggest
podcaster come out say something we'll
craft some line for you we'll take your
music down for a couple months we'll
quietly put it back up no one will say
anything you'll get tons of press people
will buy tickets to your shows that's it
that's American politics politics is pop
culture people are losing their minds
they're throwing bricks at each other's
faces because of dumb people like this
I mean an alternative explanation could
be that they just didn't realize that it
would have ultimately no impact on
whether or not who is making more money
for Spotify yeah Joe Rogan yeah and it
is full group that nobody's heard of and
they're really famous they were they are
but I mean anymore how much money are
they making off of streams I mean
anywhere close to Joe Rogan that's
that's right from the demographics that
are actually watching and listening to
Spotify particularly I didn't care about
their over-inflated egos they came
crawling back and then saying that
they're gonna like give their proceeds
to charity for episode 19 disinformation
to me that that seems like a very soft
Landing for them to return to say well
we're not doing this for ourselves we're
just doing this for everybody else I
don't know why they left to begin with
Neil Young was the thorn and he probably
called Stills Nash and
um Crosby and was like dudes we gotta
stop something something my my politics
and they're like well Neil knows what
he's talking about all right Neil got
your back and then they left and they're
like what are we doing this is
ridiculous I mean any anybody who left
the band anyway anybody who knows
anything about Crosby Stills Nash and
Youngs they've always been Ardent
authoritarians supporting the machine
and the government this is par for the
course for who they represent their song
Four Dead in Ohio about the Kent State
shootings in support of it was all about
supporting the shooting yeah I mean
they're about the most
anti-authoritarian band in the 70s no
but one of them one of the comments on
this article was like about the fact
that they're Baby Boomers and baby
boomers are all about having the
appearance of being like freedom
fighting underdogs but they're actually
like totally Pro system
I wonder if it's like when you're
younger you just give the middle finger
to the previous generation and then when
you're older you're like the Next
Generation they started right right
right I don't think he was ever like
that before didn't the Baby Boomers
start that I don't think so I mean
there's that joke from The Simpsons we
like to reference where Abe Simpson is
like I used to be with it but then they
changed what it was now what it is as
scary you know you know that bit and
then he's like it'll happen to you too
radio radicalize the Youth of the time
and then TV it was the TV generation
fine I was like look at what we are we
can't have men beating women it's not
normal like we got to fix something
about Society because in the TV shows
they'd be smacking and smacking they're
like wow what Have We Become
um so they were kind of the first
generation that was I like Sean
Connery's
does he do that yeah there's a video of
him like talking about why it's quality
and what's the value of it and all that
really yeah it was well after it was
like decided good on him I know these
guys just because of TV and mass media
this is like the mass media generation
wasn't there like some singer who had
beat his kids with a sack of oranges
because the the it hurts you but the
damage is to the Flesh of the orange so
it doesn't show marks or something like
that oh my gosh yeah that's pretty
brutal dude like the side what are this
is like the silent generation or The
Lost Generation the World War II
generation they were brutal were they
the greatest Generation I think when we
started naming that was like when the
mistakes started happening I mean was it
the Lost Generation is it the last one
like the the first one we haven't
recorded or something that's like the
late 1800s 1800s yeah the silent
generation no that was that silent
afterwards yeah and then the greatest
Generation but there's like it's like
it's like there's like overlap because
you know so it's hard to Define
different Generations because there's
there's always going to be some some
overlap between them because people have
kids all the time yeah so it's not like
it's not like every seven years everyone
goes into a chamber to have children and
they're very and there are various like
social events that will that will Define
a generation that they go through
certain experiences that you know when
you when you're towards the beginning or
towards the end of that generation
you're going to have some blend with the
other lifetime experiences as well like
you know like like Millennials have gone
through 911 and the Great Recession in
covid but you know Generation Z or
whatever what have you hasn't gone
through some of those earlier things
yeah so but there's going to be some
blend between the two where the two
intersect I wonder how that's going to
affect gen z
um obviously the older generation had uh
depending on which generation you had
Vietnam and things like that in the
draft to the Boomers and then with the
Millennials you had 911 and so you know
I don't know how old you are you do
you're a woman so do you mention your
age yeah sometimes it depends on you
know I I have before I'm 34. I can say
that okay yeah so sometimes you know
what I always say is I think I'm 34.
yeah you just ask a woman are you old
enough to or if I ask your age you'll be
offended and then you get a general idea
uh but we so we we had we all
experienced 911 but you didn't Mary no I
was a year old right right so the cow
yeah so you didn't I wonder how that's
going to uh impact impact your view of
the world relative to everyone else
because you're kind of like a nihilistic
I don't think I'm a nihilist because I'm
Catholic so sure that's right I don't
think I represent other people in my
generation either
um for that very reason it's like is Gen
Z going to be more based or more woke
you know what I mean so far like I would
like to say more bass but really the the
realities were just more polarized so
like more extreme on both ends
yeah so when the Millennials are in
charge and then you're going to have gen
Z gen Alpha and then what comes after
Alpha
Alpha I don't even know
yes dude that's when the rise
Alpha is like the tablet babies during
covid who didn't see a human face
and they can't read like these kids they
can't talk yeah they they screwed yup
yeah you ever you guys ever see that
story about the like these scientists
found a young girl that was like Raised
by Wolves or something yeah and she
couldn't learn English right because her
brain had moved on to a certain level of
development where you need you need to
have Society in order for your brain
those neurons to connect and when and if
your your brain develops beyond that
point before they connect you can't
develop the ability to to use language
yeah she could say like grunts she could
be like eat food wow yeah I think water
that that girl she was um she was held
captive by her father until she was like
found it was that what it was you're
right she eventually was able to use
language but she never
was was ever like you know but it's like
yeah like she was never able to be
independent at all like think about it
this way too there are people who are
extremely brilliant but when they like
they don't speak English when they learn
English they can't use English the same
way a proficient English speaker would
because their brains have already like
hardened right so that's why you'll
you'll see people who are like in their
50s learn English you can speak to them
you can communicate but for some reason
they won't say like the or or or you
know and or in like I think it depends
on how many languages they've learned
before that though for sure I'm just
saying that they're very intelligent
people who in their native tongue could
explain to you theories of the universe
but in English you know say like me like
eat pizza fun and you're like I got the
idea
say it in your you know first language
and you're going to be like the
beautiful thing about pizza is when you
get the cheese and the sauce and it's
all melty and delicious but they just
don't they don't speak properly you know
what I mean they're Salvador Dali is a
good example of that he was like the the
first artist of the TV generation of
like the mass media as we know it radio
TV and he was just Spanish you know I
think it's Spanish is his native
language barely spoke English very rough
and you could tell he's like brilliantly
talking about the Fibonacci sequence and
his art if you've ever seen Dali's
artist the most surrealist and amazing
stuff but when he speaks English it's
like you can barely understand what he's
saying and people just sit there and
kind of get bored which is unfortunate
because he was such a genius yeah and
people it's funny uh oftentimes
Americans assume someone's dumb they're
they're unintelligent because they're
not that good at speaking English they
don't speak English Americans are some
of the most like gracious about that
because so many people have immigrated
here I think it depends though I I don't
know I've seen both sides of that yeah I
mean but like try to speak French in
France they're going to be mean to you
when I went to Spain they were mean to
me and I can actually speak like baby
kindergarten level Spanish yeah and they
would like man I was surprised I think
in America we at least appreciate that
someone is trying yeah I think it also
but it also depends on the size of the
country too and the the level of of
spread of that language across the world
if it's a smaller country with a smaller
language or a language that's spoken by
fewer people they definitely will
appreciate the effort I think there's a
through line with Crosby Stills Nash and
Young with this because people from that
generation their brains have formed and
now with this new information of the age
it's like yeah they knew that Vietnam
was screwed they knew that there was
maybe false Flags they they knew but
they didn't quite understand the the
liberal economic order
um whatever you want to call it this
this world order thing that had been
established they didn't understand
people they definitely will there was
like a multinational corporate attempted
a takeover of the planet it didn't they
just thought like
righteousness is good the American
government's bad let's let's work it out
I don't understand then why do why do
Boomers trust authoritarian
regimes like so easily like why do they
trust Authority so automatically
uh they got a lot of value from the
American dream I put in quotes they
really sucked off the teat of the
American just Mass printing of money
from 1950 to 1990 they they became so
wealthy and safe the worst thing is they
think they earned all of it yeah right
like it was their hardware and then they
call Millennials entitled yeah we were a
colonizer they are entitled but the
boomers are like just as entitled if not
boomers are um a Boomers did a lot of
really good things but I feel like all
generations have their good side and
their bad side and it's increasingly
getting polarized so they're they're the
Boomers who are The Lazy layabouts with
snow plow parents who raised really
awful children and then there's the
Boomers who made things like Star Trek
the Next Generation and you know pursued
civil liberties and and to this day we
still have people you know that are that
are boomers that are doing well it's
just that
you know I think when we complain we
focus on the bad and ignore the fact
that we did get some really awesome
stuff I would not be here today if they
were not good Boomers who did something
right sure and the people listening to
the show and you know like everyone
else's parents it's just like we are
focused on the bad so they're good
Millennials too like obviously we're
Millennials and you know we're doing all
right I think so and then there are bad
Millennials who are screaming that like
their rent should be free so but like
what portion are each of those sides
yeah I don't know I wonder you need data
on that yeah but I genuinely feel like
when you look at most social media
Millennials are a messed up
let me see if I can pull up this story
let me see if I can try and try and find
a story we're gonna jump ahead a little
bit and I'll tell you how messed up
Millennials are here we go oh this I got
this uh tweet where I wrote brain rot it
is a woman and she's 11.6 million views
she posts on her Tick Tock lost a
patient today and then she's like she
set up the camera she's filming herself
she leans up against the wall Shake It
Off you five more hours she's a nurse or
whatever or a doctor I don't know maybe
a fancy doctor and this right here is is
is in my opinion the exact like the
problem with everything it's not just
millennials
it's the younger generation on social
media they're all doing this they are
desperate for validation and attention
and so everything about their lives is
fake made up
this is very scary right so we saw some
tragedies take place in in a couple
cities Philadelphia and in Highland Park
and why does that kind of thing happen
well we have to talk about it these guys
want their name in the news they want to
be on TV they want people to know who
they are they want to be a part of
History
they're often loners on antidepressants
things like that so it all makes sense
no one is giving them the time of day
humans are social creatures who crave
social interaction
this is on the same wavelength
totally opposite ends like okay some
lady made a fake video where she
pretended to mourn and it's very vapid
and all that stuff fine she didn't go
and hurt anybody so they're very very
different but there's a similar thread
stitching these things in that people
are they will do whatever it takes to
get those likes on social media so that
they can feel validated because they
don't have the mental fortitude to feel
good about themselves on their own this
is the millennial generation gen Z is
very similar all of these I remember I
went to VidCon I think it was like 2016.
and there were these little kids so this
is eight years ago this is or six years
ago this is crazy there were a bunch of
little kids and as I'm walking past them
one ghost how many followers do you have
I have 43 and he goes I got 82. you have
82 followers and I was like those kids
are going to be messed up that's where
we're going garyvee will tell kids that
don't worry about the number of
followers you have focus on the quality
and having fun and being happy and
making things we like but this this
video is a perfect example of why the
country is imploding and it really
really is think about it what we see
with virtue signaling the woke people
Ellen Page you better you better delete
that Viral Trend because you said the
wrong name yo 99 of people I I guarantee
you if you walk down the street in any
major city and said do you know who
Elliot page is they'd be like no and if
you said do you know Allen Pages they'd
be like oh yeah yeah from X-Men but did
you know that it's bigoted to say that
name they'd be like I have no idea yet
those people would innocently go on
Twitter and say something like big fan
of Ellen Page in those movies she is
super cool and then banned not allowed
that's happening because these people
are like I'm gonna get attention here's
a really good example did you guys see
that what's his name Griffin green do
you guys hear about this guy you heard
about him right uh Bodega bro oh oh yeah
I didn't know his real name I only knew
Bodega bro Bodega bro so there's this
dude this is an amazing story he moved
to New York for a job and he's this
really kind of like
I don't know what the right word is
doofy like it's like an endearing kind
of
um uh General ignorance okay I'm not I'm
not insulting I'm saying he just didn't
understand New York so it's probably a
good thing to be ignorant of for sure
New York City but so he's walking around
and he's like I'm trying to find a
grocery store in New York I can't find
anything and he's like ever it keeps
Google Maps keeps sending me to these
places he's like yo what's going on and
it's like they're making a sandwich it's
a bodega someone
reported him to his company they're like
are you going to employ this person so
they fire him
people get mad at this dude who reported
him and so then that dude makes a video
where he's like I'm being harassed on
the internet you have no idea what it
feels like when people are coming after
you and it's like bro you just did this
these people their brains are are putty
it's mush they're going on social media
and they're like I'm gonna get attention
by tattletailing on someone and then
it's just a big swarm of people throwing
flinging crap at each other yeah all for
the sake of getting more clicks getting
more attention to the point where yo
someone died I don't actually know if
someone died she could be faking it but
you're gonna be wearing your scrubs
frame your camera get it set up press
record look back check your hair stand
back and then go oh this is the same
callousness yeah well I think human life
I think really what's happening here to
me anyway my impression is that we've
really just commodified connection which
is something that ultimately we really
need like you said we're so we are
social creatures so all humans need
connection and so as our as our
technology gets more and more advanced
that that is supposed to ironically
bring us together more and more we are
ironically being sort of forced apart
more so and especially since the
pandemic so you know that combine that
with the American tendency to
um I mean this is going back to my my
college days of of Sociology classes
that I took
um on like our our American
cultural roots of being
um uh cultural roots in Calvinism and
and
um Puritans and that kind of stuff that
like they would look for signs of being
being a part of the the saved you know
the the part of you know going yeah yeah
exactly the elect reaching salvation and
whatnot they would look for signs for
that being like you know signs of of
wealth it means that you're not spending
your money it means that you are
accumulating your wealth it means that
you are working very hard very
diligently so those were all virtues so
we just as a culture from our very very
cultural early historical underpinnings
we have um had a long tradition of sort
of commodifying our virtuos so it makes
a lot of sense that in the age of social
media and the age of likes and
subscribes and shares that that's the
way that we'll we'll view those Virtues
Of of having connection having a
personal connection with with other
individuals and it's and especially
um like a clip like that that has a lot
of emotion involved in it I mean we're
talking about death we're talking about
grief that is a pretty strong
um I guess you could say Force for
somebody to want to give some kind of
connection to that kind of emotion I
think uh
you're you're right about the
commodification of virtual stuff but
there was a
a unified message in this country so
that commodification was mostly unified
a single track when the Dixie Chicks I
think it was you know the Dixie Chicks
are yeah you do okay when they came out
I think they criticized the war right
that's what happened yeah the war in
Iraq George W bush and then it was like
it was a bad thing it got canceled they
got canceled now that now they're just
called to go by the chicks yeah now
they're just the chicks we were joking
me and Brett were joking that like you
can't call women chicks anymore so
there's gonna be the
you can't it's offensive uh but back
then even though most like your
Democrats Republicans and you had a big
anti-war movement the mainstream
narrative was don't rag on the soldiers
or criticism of the war was Crimson of
the soldiers something happened and I
think it's a lot to do with the internet
where a Divergent culture emerged we
split and two markets developed you had
a market for out angst and wokeness and
you had a market for opposing It Free
Speech Liberty Freedom all that stuff
kind of where we ended up and then that
that market split it probably could have
been stopped if in the in the late 2000s
someone came out was like yo yo yo yo we
are we're hard forking here as an
American culture but no one did anything
so American culture forked and I think
it has a lot to do with in cities with
the internet messaging spread so rapidly
that the left dramatically changed their
position faster than the right could
keep in touch keep in line with it
there's a good there's a good example
like maybe pull up in a second from the
New York Times where it shows in 2008
the left veers off like that and the
right just keeps going when that
happened you end up with tens of
millions of people all with money
creating a massive Market opportunity
for woke virtue signaling that will
never stop so at this point I would I
would say you know I was trying to I was
wondering like how do we stop the
country from collapsing like what are
the real solutions and and I don't want
to say it's black pill to think this I
think it's more realism you can't and
the reason is there is money to be made
if you are woke there is money to be
made if you are anti-woke this means
that market forces and political forces
necessitate the expand the expansion of
messaging in favor of these two massive
groups you could disincentivize money
and focus more on goods and services I
think that's a that's something that
could keep us together is how do we get
the grain from Kansas around the country
so we can all eat
that and I mean there's also the the
possibility that people get over
saturated by it and people get tired of
it and then eventually they they want to
find something that is a little bit more
more moderated
I just watched a documentary on BuzzFeed
uh yesterday I think it was yesterday
day before and how they were really
leading spearheading this what you were
calling a commodification of of well
that's called hate or whatever but like
2012-13 it's like uh identity politics
they'd be like 25 things that black
people can identify with 12 things that
women really want well so 18 things a
gay man can get down with and you're
like all of a sudden it's getting then
it's like a blast game man and then it
then it's hate gets involved like four
things that you just women just can't
stand and then Boston bombing people are
profiting off of the news anyway I could
go on I'm gonna break I'm gonna break
that down I'm gonna show this real quick
and then explain what Ian's saying so
this is what happened to the the
political center from The New York Times
and you can see in 2008 the left the
Democratic party look at look at that
chart just look at that the blue line
shooting super far left you see where it
says median party that's the median
party of Europe
so the United States for some reason in
eight years became left of center for
European political parties which are
already relatively far left now of
course the left will look at that and
say oh see we're only Center left
Republican party is far right and it's
like no no that's American culture You
can disagree with it but this shows the
left went far left relative to where
Americans are and I'll tell you how it
happened as Dean was pointing out
BuzzFeed was creating articles where it
was like about black people about gay
people those were buzzwords the
algorithm would latch onto words and
then pump them out and what happens I
remember this man you guys probably
remember this too I don't know if you
remember this all the police brutality
videos all that's all Facebook was it
was like you'd go on Facebook and it was
just endless videos of police brutality
rap songs about police brutality that's
all it was so what happens is you get
companies like BuzzFeed where they're
like hey we got a million Clicks in the
police brutality video why well because
people don't like Injustice then they
were like hey hey I made an article that
was talking about police brutality and
racism you got twice as many views
so they start cramming all the different
keywords as possible into as many
articles as possible
and then you get intersectional feminism
and it's not and then they'll be like
hey there's no racist violent things
that happen today what's our next
article going to be it's not that
they're going out there and creating the
racist violence necessarily but there is
an incentive to see more racist violence
and you will literally as a as a someone
that does that stuff hope for something
like that to happen so that you can make
a lot of money off it it's you can soak
so here's here's the fight here's the
political battle can you can you pull
this back up the New York Times thing if
you are in the middle of the road
um from 2000 you're let's say you were
the Democrat you weren't the Republican
you are moderate you're in between you
likely did not get pulled far left along
with the Democratic party you probably
floated somewhere in the middle like
this Like Me Maybe to a certain extent a
bit like Ian or a bit like Joe Rogan or
Elon Musk so now if you were in the
middle
the Republican Party well they're kind
of right wing compared to where I am but
the left I can't even see where they're
at so this is what happens there was a
tweet from Libby Emmons about how the
Democrats went so pro-abortion that a
lot of people just were like like
Democrats were like yo I'm out and they
lost the fight they had no support
anymore and then I see this on Twitter
the commodification of virtue the
centrists are just far right the center
has moved far right the the moderates
are being radicalized and I'm just like
if you are in the Democratic party and
you veered that far left you don't think
you moved you're the same normal person
you've always been it's like if you go
underwater and then you look up at
people on the surface you're like
everyone's blurry now exactly but like
dude that's because get out of the water
and everyone's still normal man so so
here's the issue though these people
they build the following they've got
millions of followers they can't just
stop CNN they used to be they used to
cover the news now it's just orange man
bad all day every day January 6 and
whatever they can milk out of it
if CNN comes out now and says we're
going to go back to reporting the news
no one will watch them because they'll
lose the Zealot fans they got and they
already lost the news fans they well
they lost them a long time ago so they
have no choice it's an addiction and
they've done it to themselves yeah I was
just I was just thinking that I think
that an important factor in that is the
the actual emotional addiction or maybe
not emotional but the addiction that
some people actually have to to these
emotions that they feel
um with regard to these these uh various
stories rage is a big one
um what's her face that uh when she she
testified in front of Congress about
Facebook
um this was I don't know how many months
ago
um one of the she was a former she was
supposed to be working on there like all
right their election yeah yeah yeah the
Facebook was that quote yeah
um but she was talking about that how
she she had said that there was there
was some kind of studies I'm I'm really
reaching back without having looked at
this after months but
um she was saying that that was that was
one of the one of the one of the big
issues is that is that people were
actually having there they were showing
signs of addiction to to rage and so
it's like how do you get somebody
off of that off of that sort of a
substance when it's everywhere and
there's every incentive for them to
continue profiting off of it well so
there there are um
Dave rubin's got this Joe Rogan's got
this I've obviously got this there are
people who take Clips out of context on
purpose because they know there's a
market for tribal rage so we try to have
people on the left on the show and we've
had a few but I would say the
overwhelming majority of them won't come
on they'll cancel they refuse or they'll
use it to Rally their base because
they're virtue signalers so there's one
guy in particular who's like oh come on
and then when we actually were like okay
sure he he privately says I'm not
actually doing it then goes to his fans
and blames me for for not allowing it
and now uses that to rile them up and
say see what I told you and it's crazy
because I'm like yo we genuinely tried
to have some of these people on and they
legit spit on us and laughed and said
now we're going to make money off you
then they go to their base and say
they're with the actual bad guys so this
is the crazy thing
we are trying to get those people out of
the cult they think we're in the cult
but these are the people who believe
Jessie Smollett these are the people who
believed Russia gate these are the
people who believed hands up don't shoot
these are the people who believe the
Covington kids story these are the
people who believed Ukraine these are
the people who believe the very fine
people hoax these are the people who
never once stopped to actually check the
evidence themselves
and there are many of them and they have
money and their money is easily parted
from them by these people that is the
Big Challenge and so long as there are
these prominent left-wing personalities
who will Pander to them there's there's
going to be a division that is moving us
towards catastrophe but that being said
this next story is a bit more of good
news from the Washington examiner Joe
Rogan will never have Trump on podcast
not interested in helping him now that
isn't the story I'm actually pointing
out you have to dig a Little Deeper to
see what the what the big story is and
it's where Joe Rogan says Trump is
running against a dead man
that's the important point Joe Rogan has
praised Ron DeSantis saying he'd be a
good president he doesn't want to help
Trump but if the regular person if Joe
Rogan is the barometer for UFC
commentator mainstream comedian
I'd be willing to bet Joe Rogan is where
most Americans probably are
and they are not far left they are tired
of the woke stuff they don't like Donald
Trump Rhonda Santos will probably be all
right that's good news it means that
cult may have been breaking itself so
far off from the mainstream America that
eventually they're going to lose money
run out and then they're not going to be
a part of the economy anymore and when
that market dries up people start
walking away I have to imagine with Joe
Rogan being who he is for the past
several years saying what he said a lot
of regular people are moving away from
that stuff
they're getting out of it
so
he's not threatening Joe Biden by
calling him a dead man but he's
basically pointing out that
Joe's not going to win he can't win
right I think Joe's been saying that for
a while though hasn't he Rogan yeah yeah
about button so Nano for sure for sure I
just mean like here's the latest context
around it so does he mean I'm not
interested in helping Trump because
Trump doesn't need any help at this
point
he has no competition he's saying he
doesn't I think Joe says I'm not a trump
supporter I'm not going to help him out
I'm not going to have him on the show
now that says to me Joe Rogan's taking a
hard political stance because for me as
you know like as a host of a show I I
lit I actually don't care about helping
someone or hurting someone that's
ridiculous you know uh no offense to Joe
my attitude is
if we're gonna have a conversation and
talk about these things and we need to
well maybe it'll help you or not but
it's interesting what Joe's saying right
there
that if Trump goes on his show it will
help Trump what does that mean
it means that Trump is more correct that
Trump will expose the media's lies and
that will help him obviously it'll give
him exposure but if Trump was wrong
about everything going on his show would
expose him right it would hurt him
wouldn't it
right yeah that makes sense it logically
checks out Joe thinks Trump is right
to a certain degree maybe not on
everything maybe he doesn't think he's a
good person but he thinks enough that if
Trump were to come on his show it would
benefit him or at the very least he just
thinks that Trump is a very convincing
person maybe but I think the reality is
Joe knows that uh that Rogan knows Biden
is out of it and that people elected a
guy who was burning this country to the
ground because they hate Trump trump
will come on Trump will say remember
2019 remember this policy remember when
I did this and people are gonna be like
that's true
and there is a reality to what Donald
Trump was doing when he was president
that man he had a potty mouth he was uh
he was not a nice guy in a lot of ways
he's a nice guy in a lot of ways but not
a nice guy in a lot of ways you know and
I think if people start hearing what
Trump has to say on a platform like that
it will greatly help Trump not because
he's just convincing but because he's
right it would help Trump in general to
have more public uh showings I I haven't
even seen him talk in like I think I saw
one interview with him in the last two
years I'm kind of with Joe on this in
that I think about having Donald on this
podcast because it would one it would be
great for the podcast it would have huge
numbers too you know whatever it's
political and that's all that matters is
feeding fodder Too part of me is like
wow the profitability of of selling out
wow but I don't never really I mean
Trump's just divide he's he's like
divisive I don't know I don't hate him
but I'd have Biden on the show too it's
not like I hate that you'd have them
both on yeah because of the political
prowess because they have been the
president
some interesting conversations with
either one I would love to have Biden on
this show it'd be great I would rather
have Biden than Trump you know because I
I just so barisma Victor uh shulkin
Michael zachevski let's talk Ukraine
buddy I gotta go yeah he'd be like I'm
leaving with Trump I'd say stuff like I
disagree with your fraud narrative I'd
ask him questions but Trump's issue is
that they call him a liar all the time
and I'm like maybe he's just wrong Trump
lies about dumb ego stuff like how how
big and famous he is and things like
that I don't care about him he makes
prompt big promises too with I think no
idea of how to follow through like I'm
gonna drain the swamp what did that even
mean did he even have an idea of what
that meant because he didn't fire a lot
there was an actual pool outside the
White House he was actually a swamped so
we're still waiting on that I kept my
promise by the way you can go swimming
now I can I can ask Trump so like the
things I could criticize Trump over is
like the state department was
advertising uh Trump properties in the
UK that's not okay uh Trump tried using
Doral in Florida for I think it was the
G7 that's not okay Trump eventually
rescinded then said okay I won't do it I
thought I was going to save him money
and I'm like conflict of interest
but he pulled he was pulling our troops
out of the Middle East like the one
thing you can really get him for is like
you're kind of a dick to a lot of people
and people didn't like that but so was
Joe Biden Joe Biden launched his
campaign off the very fine people hoax
it was a hoax that's the craziest thing
his campaign video was that Donald Trump
praised white nationalists which never
happened he made it up to make people
hate that is psychotic I think that I
think they're both kind of kind of a
dick like um Biden was really mean to
that that guy who was asking him about
something like the gun control guy yeah
and he just like lashed out he lashes
out at people a lot but maybe it's just
because but it's humility that could be
part of it well he's done it for years I
remember points his finger in people's
face yeah so aggressive like if he was
doing it in private okay maybe then I
would question but he did it in public
on TV right in front of the world which
is what makes him seem senile like do
you know that people are watching you
act crazy right now well it's like uh
feels like and the way he the way he
puts his finger in people's faces like
you're asking yeah it's really
aggressive the guy that'll grab your arm
really tight till it hurts yes I was
going to say the way he puts his hands
on women's shoulders and sniffs their
heads not women children well children
as well yes yeah what a creepy awful man
you know look Donald Trump locker room
talk all those nasty things I'm not a
fan of any of it and there's a lot of
people who really love Trump for who he
is his Die Hard supporters they're like
we're glad there's a guy in there who's
going to tell people and I've I've
laughed I understand what funny is when
he called stormy horse face when he's he
said only Rosie O'Donnell you know when
he called what who do you call someone a
fat pig I don't know I think it's just
something along those lines I think
entertaining funny celebrity drama me
personally I'm like maybe not in the
White House definitely I'm not in the
wild I know it happened we need lawyers
in the White House and legal analysts
and scientists and things like lawyers
like Obama so many lawyers how many one
of them is it isn't every single lawyer
joke about them being in hell I thought
Obama's pretty much Obama was a
constitutional lawyer I believe he's and
and that was valuable you know he wasn't
an idiot when it came yeah yeah he was
like if you want to circumvent to get
things done and and I remember when he
said if you're lucky I will know all the
legal loopholes for blown up kids too
many of them but we do need people to
understand the constitution in the in
the White House that re that respect the
Constitution I think constitutionalists
maybe is a better phrase than lawyers I
think Trump is what you get when the
people are neglected for too long and I
went to these Trump rallies and there
were so many people who are like I've
never voted before but I'm voting for
this man because he's finally sticking
it to the machine the Republicans and
Democrats were snooty so that they were
better than everyone else and that
needed to change so now you've got the
Trump populists the left populists hate
the Democrats and hate the Republicans
but support the Democrats because they
hate the Republicans more which is dumb
but the whole thing is just kind of
gonna it's it's falling apart I actually
think Ron DeSantis
could probably save the country
but I don't know if he'll he'll actually
reform it to the degree it needs to be
reformed he would just stop it from
imploding you know what I mean he does
seem to have the the same sort of
ability to make trump-like changes but
without his tweets
but I don't think he'd go he goes as far
as we need him to I'm also Fair Point
you know eating about this up I don't
know if Trump would drain the swamp
either he didn't do it the first time he
brought more swamp monsters and he got
rid of some of them but brought more in
maybe he was getting jammed up by the
russiagate stuff and he couldn't do it
he might win re-election and say okay
now I've got one more term I don't have
to worry about the swamp so I'm going to
ignore it
you know yeah
and if he doesn't go in there and fire
everybody then what's the point then Ron
DeSantis I think would do better now I I
mean I think you were right about his
foreign policy stuff because he was
trying to stop the war a lot of the war
in the Middle East you know maybe
heavy-handedly like moving the the
Israeli what was it what he moved to
Jerusalem he moved the uh Embassy which
is basically saying hey Palestinians Fu
you know it's basically like picking a
side in the israeli-palestinian conflict
by putting it in Jerusalem and saying
like this is an Israeli Embassy in
Jerusalem which is supposed to be split
between the Israelis and the Palestine
Palestinians
um so he that was like some kind of
Brute Force
um ignorance I think politically oh the
conservatives loved it of course half of
the people loved it the other half of
people are like what the heck one of the
things Joe Rogan brought up in this
interview with Lex Friedman that's where
the quotes come from is that they were
people who abandoned all principle and
logic to attack Trump and his supporters
because he was a threat to democracy or
something it was legitimately insane the
way they lied about Trump all day every
day and there was a meme among centrists
stop making me defend trump it was
people who are like I don't like him
either but yo that's not true that's a
really funny skit someone did and they
were like why are you saying that are
you a trump supporter no it just that
didn't happen they were like you support
Trump
it's like okay dude
I don't know how we're supposed to
survive as a country if you can't even
just be like this is what's true this is
what's not true nobody wanted journalism
they wanted confirmation bias and that
was the cult well I think one place
where I've started to see A change is in
in my corner of of YouTube which is live
streaming trials starting with the
writtenhouse trial that was the first
eye-opener for a lot of people to say oh
the media is lying to me about
everything that happened in Kenosha that
night
um and then more recently but those were
those were people that were of a
particular uh political demographic more
people on the right now we have the
Johnny Depp versus the Amber Heard trial
where people are saying the same thing
but they span the entire political
Spectrum I mean I have people that are
that are literal socialists that are
saying the media is lying to us about
this what else are they lying to us
about good so it's it's if if you're if
you're looking for for a potential
ground for for change
um on social media or on the internet in
generally that could be one of those
places yeah the mega corporate internet
Media or the mega corporate media
apparatus is it's just the the fact the
fact that the reporting on these trials
is just so different and when people
have the ability to actually watch them
for themselves and to evaluate the
evidence evaluate the arguments that are
put in front of them and to understand
the law that's actually at play
um they they're they're able to come to
their own conclusions and this is I
think one of the reasons why channels
like like mine like Roketa law like Viva
fry um Emily D Baker a bunch of other
people on on law in law tube like we
like to call it the reason why these
channels are growing is because we're
giving people the ability to make their
own conclusions using the evidence and
just sort of like acting as as almost
like like law Sherpas to like guide them
through the process yeah I think um
schooling is kind of uh obtuse in a lot
of ways like they make people go to
medical school for 12 years or something
to learn how to do something that you
could really learn how to do regardless
of the amount of time it's going to take
you you could learn how to do it same
with law if you can learn the info why
do you have to spend 600 000 in uh 11
years or whatever eight years like so
you guys credential yeah you guys are
kind of teaching the information without
the badge you know without and and the
process too like that actually is the
part that I think is is more confounding
to most people is not so much the the
actual information but the the legal
process like what is trial actually like
what is litigation actually like because
you know well everybody comes in contact
with the law regardless of whether
they're in litigation at some point in
their lives or not but most people will
come in contact with a legal process at
some point as well whether that's
criminal law or litigation like civil
litigation or probate you know
somebody's parent dies and they have to
administer a trust you know or or a will
or something like that and and and
automatically there's I mean part of it
is the is the expense but automatically
there's a lot of fear for most people so
you know if you can if you can help
people understand the process
um that they are that they're about to
enter into it eliminates a lot of fear
like I I had somebody on on Twitter that
um tweeted at me and several others
saying um I am a DV Survivor I'm
supposed to testify against my against
my abuser you know next week or next
month or something like that and now
after having watched the deputy herd
trial with all of you guys I have way
less fear about what to expect because I
I understand the process now did you see
the journalists during the Amber uh the
the Devin heard thing where they were
like I can't remember who it was but
they said the court actually claimed
that there was malice look at what
Johnny Depp did to her and it's like
they have no idea what they're talking
about they don't they don't look at the
at the legal filings or the language and
say what does that mean yeah they say I
know what it means I don't need
assistance and Malice legally does not
mean the same thing as malice
colloquially right so actual malice
actual Mouse yeah so so these
journalists are writing nonsense and
they're like the court actually claimed
there was malice despite Johnny Depp
having been accused of doing X Y and Z
and it's like that has nothing to do
with what the Court's saying yeah the
court saying she knew what she was
saying or either she knew what she was
saying was wrong or was Reckless
disregard for the truth that's it right
yeah exactly when Roe v Wade dropped you
know I did I was like whoa I better call
a lawyer
it's crazy I think that the big
difference between the corporate Press
today and whatever this show is and
whatever your show is is that we're very
much like Hey we're probably wrong let's
ask experts and see what they have to
say about this journalism
now mainstream corporations are like we
know because we're smart it's very
scientific method form of Journalism
assume that you're wrong until you can
replicate it and figure out that what
exactly it is
uh so it should be done I think should
be but isn't so now we we
I mean I I guess
going back six seven years trust in the
Press has been at all-time lows so good
fine but they're still getting tons of
money they're still controlling the news
cycle they're still manipulating the
narrative
and we got we got it we gotta we gotta
change that and take it over
I've been thinking about this and the
interesting thing is
Millennials are going to take over soon
you've got boomers are starting to
retire out gen xers are taking the reins
however for some reason Gen X is just
ignored have you guys have you noticed
this like there's never a part of the
conversation okay Millennials are going
to start inheriting these machines and
you look at people like Taylor Lorenz
yeah she's a millennial she she is is
she
I'm sorry I don't mean that it's a joke
I mean that I mean that actually because
I I know that there's a lot about her
age and I'm I'm just genuinely confused
okay well that's our understanding I
think she lied about her age once as a
joke and now it's got everyone twisted
and confused okay Bill Maher in
referencing The Washington Post fighting
with Felicia sonmez said this is why
Millennials we don't want you to take
over because you're a bunch of whiny
entitled brats and the Felicia sonmez
thing was hilarious did you see that one
you guys know this one yeah it was
happening around the same time Dave
Weigel their star reporter or a star
reporter retweeted a joke where it said
the joke was every woman is bi you just
have to figure out if it's polar or
sexual
and so he retweeted that she complained
he got suspended without pay she would
not stop attacking the company she gets
fired Bill Maher was like this is the
problem with Millennials well it's the
problem with the Millennials the
institutions I'll tell you this the
Millennials who aren't there have
started companies they're becoming
successful they're working in separate
Industries and and it's the problem is
that bill he missed this he's like
Millennials oh look at him at the
Washington Post like yeah yeah we don't
associate with them either and we're
Millennials we're starting our own
businesses we're starting our own
channels we're starting our own websites
we're building up our own subscription
bases the people who can't do that are
begging The Washington Post for a job
and then crying all day until they're
fired see the difference so the
Washington Post will probably crumble
under the under the girth of its
entitlement from Millennials and then
the daily wire Tim cast legal bites Viva
fry all of these channels are going to
start growing hiring people expanding or
remaining as independent personalities
who can fund themselves
as you were saying that I was thinking
of I think it's less about what
generation you were born in and more
about your state of mind there are a lot
of independent creators that span aged
80 to age 11 or age 17 but that people
that are born more recently are have
been born more into Nanny State
um basically it's like a technocracy
that they're trying to build where it's
like a spy State and so they have this
appeal to Authority where they maybe
they're you may be more likely to appeal
to Authority or may find yourself around
people that are more likely to not that
it not that you're bound by your
generation to behave a certain way
but it's just the nature of the gradient
has been shifting
I think right now if you want to be rich
it's simple make not woke content that's
it
yeah and a platform you can do it on I
suppose so if you uh start a rumble
channel do comedy that's it so much
comedy is just really really awful I
think Rogan was also talking about this
that woke Comics are just really bad
maybe it wasn't Rogan so I probably
probably Rogan I feel like I've heard
him say something I don't know if
anti-woke Comics are that much better uh
but look if your comic is obsessed with
wokeness that's their whole bit maybe
yeah but I mean being anti-woke is like
such an obsession too now but I'm not
saying
um
like woke Comics aren't always joking
about race and and white supremacy
they're avoiding these subjects so there
was one video I watched where it was a a
woke comic and he was mocking himself
and I'm like it's just not funny I mean
I guess Rodney Dangerfield
self-deprecating humor and stuff can
work but then you watch people anti-woke
I don't mean their Comics who are
literally attacking woke people I mean
Ryan long for instance he's anti-woke
not that he comes out every bit and just
makes fun of wokeness but that he's
willing to tell offensive jokes that
don't fall in line with wokeness you
know what I mean would you say Dave
Chappelle and like Ricky Gervais sort of
types of comics kind of for the most
part the willingness to be offensive and
and you know Dave Chappelle did a bit in
his comedy special back in 2018 where he
he did like a Chinese stereotype and it
was just really old school racist
Chinese stereotypes and everyone laughed
at it like that's anti-woke right like
he was purposefully poking people and
being offensive but in his most isn't
special he was real defensive they got
him they gotta run for his money so uh
Ryan Long's got a bit right now where
he's a he's a singer saying that it's
women's right to get an abortion
specifically one woman and then he names
a woman who he's like I accidentally
knocked up and you better get a divorce
so it's funny that's comedy that's the
joke but it's as offensive as you can
get when he when he does his routines
that's anti-wopeness disregard for
wellness ignoring it it's funny I think
that stuff's gonna keep growing and
working I mean we we we're talking so we
we do the cast Castle Vlog if you
haven't uh subscribed go to youtube.com
cast castle and we're doing skits and
bits and it's relatively family friendly
stuff and silly slapstick humor and you
know like Mary's like lurking in the
closet in the attic for some reason like
some weirdo screaming flash in the light
yeah stuff like that but we've been
we've been talking about um even with
Sheamus from Freedom Tunes Sheamus
mentioned this we had a bit a couple of
them that YouTube would never allow that
are actually family friendly but they
offend the political sensibilities of
YouTube Weird vaccine jokes like just
mocking the political you know air
around it and stuff like that and we
were like yeah if we made that skit it
would not be offensive to any parent
children could watch it and ask their
parents what it meant it wasn't lewd or
anything like that it was just you know
about politics but YouTube would delete
it
for wrong think that's the crazy thing
so that means there's a huge market for
humor on Rumble
so if like you if you do comedy just
start making Rumble videos and they'll
go viral because people are looking for
things to laugh at the daily wire is
growing so rapidly because the hole in
the market is so big
that like I think the daily wires got
like four or five movies and they're
close to a million subscribers
four or five
hey the opportunity is right man people
don't want this stuff just gotta do it
well that's I mean that's why I was
saying earlier is that you know
sometimes people will have an
oversaturation and there will be a
reaction to that so with that comes in
an opening in the market for people to
to try to
to try to you know get something you
know some kind of a product or a service
that that otherwise fills fills the void
that exists because everybody else is
over saturating that market being
wokeism yeah I'm just wary of anyone
who's trying to sell something anti-woke
anti-cancel culture
but doing so well sanitizing the entire
topic like I think Pierce Morgan
uncensored does exactly that oh he's
awesome he's like I'm canceling cancel
culture like it's okay threatening
anything you're not pushing any boundary
and no one is afraid of appearing on
Pierce more and uncensored yeah you know
it's it's yeah it's gimmicky it's cheap
it doesn't mean anything to anyone I
mean even even the after show that we do
is like moderately okay we'll swear a
lot and we'll say things that offend
delicate woke sensibilities but even we
are not extreme Edge Lords just trying
to poke the bear as hard as possible
we're just trying to speak freely you
know Piers Morgan is
it's uncensored but it's it's like as
Normy as you're gonna get hmm he's like
let's talk about this controversial
subject it's like everyone's talking
about that Jordan Peterson was talking
about that five years ago come on man
but but outside of you know when we're
talking about comedy I'm not I'm not
saying if somebody makes a show where
their whole shtick is woke people bad
it's like okay we get it like just make
good stuff tear on the Prairie The Daily
wires movie it's not like a bunch of you
know woke people on Horseback with
purple hair right up and they're like oh
no we gotta fight back it's just a
western it's just the west and it's a
woman and she's like I'm gonna fight
they're like we made a movie it's a
story that's it it's not anti-wogue it's
not woke it's just a movie yeah like if
you have a field of crops and all the
crops are dying the way to combat that
isn't by like making fun of dying crops
it's to grow crops the right way exactly
that's it it's good metaphor well that's
that's why you know we started pop
culture crisis it's because we I was
like look the two things we don't want
to do is make welt content that's a
given we don't like it but also
anti-woke content where all we do is
just be like oh look at this look at
that it comes up you know in like you
know Seth Rogen is that a thing on
Twitter we'll be like oh that was dumb
but it's not like we dedicate everything
to just going after wokeness that's what
it was very much like in the 20 early
YouTube era and I feel that's why a lot
of those early YouTubers bowed out quit
or failed it's like dude you can't have
your whole identity be based on someone
else's identity that's true you need
your own you need to stand up for what
you believe in and talk about that stuff
that's why I also really don't like
talking about people like Taylor Lorenz
and stuff granted she specifically
represents a very powerful brand she she
was in a high high position until she
got demoted and so that's more
representation of institutional power
but I try to keep it to the the news and
the info and so that we can have a real
conversation around this stuff you know
yeah yeah it's exhausting to try and um
make a career off of talking about
what's wrong with other things because
then you're always looking for new
problems and to the point where you may
be happy to see them get created it's
insane insane way to live it's not
healthy I don't think that's a very good
point
I think people regular people
that are just totally ignorant don't
know they don't know anything about
what's going on they don't know what
Rumble is and that's one of the big
challenges so so long as we keep working
we keep growing we keep marketing I'll
say uh parlor had a Times Square
billboard good the more people who see
that and ask what is that the better we
we obviously had our Time Square
Billboards we had Ian up on a big 40
some odd foot screen uh the 70-foot
screen the biggest one rejected our ad
because they said the word politics was
in it that's all that matters like they
don't care about us or anything like
that but they were like the word Camp
politics we can't do anything with that
uh the daily wires had a couple
different Billboards up in Times Square
taking these cultural spaces is
extremely important I've been getting
tons of ads on Reddit and Facebook for
the daily wire and I'm glad every time I
see it because these spaces have been
ignored by
I I whatever you want to call it the
anti-woke factions or whatever
the ads aren't explicitly like woke this
is bad it's just like hey watch our show
good
we had um I think we were talking with
Billy prempe he was running for as a
republican in a very blue area and
Kimberly classic she was running in a
very blue area and I was like good
the like these Republicans have
abandoned Urban centers because like
what's the point we're not going to win
and my response is
a person who uh uh what is it saying a
society that uh
uh grows great when a person plants
trees whose shade they know they will
never sit beneath
so if you start campaigning as a
republican in New York City you're not
going to win but you're planting trees
man of course you're not going to get an
orange in your first season it's going
to take 10 20 years before that that you
know fruit that that plant bears fruit
there's balance you don't want to plant
trees where you know they're going to
get mowed down and destroyed in the next
five years because like it'd be like
going to a war zone to talk to be open
and honest you're going to get killed in
the war zone so like you do want to
plant your your psychological trees in
places that maybe aren't the easiest to
grow but you've got to make sure that
you're not wasting your time at the same
time Fair Point that's true too but I
feel like that's one of the biggest
problems we have in this country is that
Democrats and Republicans both at some
point said if I can't win easily I won't
waste my time and now you're getting
hyperpolarization
so we need to make things for
the other side yeah it's not about
winning it's not it's about doing you
don't need to win every competition you
just need to participate I mean it's the
joy of participation I think that may
have be maybe lost in society I had to
learn how to lose and to love it or no
one would play games with me because I
would beat them at video games over and
over and over and over then they'd quit
and I'd be like well now so I don't
actually let them win without them
knowing so that they would keep playing
and I had to find joy and like just the
process I've heard some some studies
about like uh and the animals will
actually do that too because there's an
importance of of play that that comes
with the learning process so so even
it's not just humans but but other
animals will do that they'll there's
like a certain like percentage of time
that like an older animal or a bigger
animal will during play time will allow
the the smaller or younger animal
actually win because otherwise they
don't want to discourage them from
playing with them in the free in the
future so we need more Democrats and
Republicans letting Republicans
Democrats win or or allowing for the
possibility that they'll lose at some
point understanding that there will be
something in the process in the long run
that will benefit everybody
I think I think the issue is the
American cultures are just too Divergent
we don't even speak the same language
anymore
yeah same words with with altered uh
definitions sometimes the culture has
diverged so far in this country we don't
speak the same language I don't know I
think it depends on on the subject
matter because you know like again like
I said I'm I'm the fact that I'm I'm
seeing on my channel my my viewers have
very much Diversified in in their in
their politics and a lot of that comes
from the fact that the the reason why
they've come to my channel in the first
place is not politics it's something
else that is that is politics adjacent I
mean law is definitely has a lot of
overlaps with politics as well but it's
something that that everyone really
cares about this whole like mass of
people cares about but it's not politics
exactly but it's the kind of thing that
that introduces them to other
conversations that we have about law
that also overlaps with a lot of these
topics too maybe the challenge is we
need some kind of service guaranteeing
citizenship right you guys are familiar
with that that's from Starship Troopers
yeah service guarantee citizenship
um and I said that in some form the
issue is when you have low uh
what's the right word to say this
uninterested individuals they're not
interested in politics they're
interested in tribal fighting they'd be
better off watching you know the Sox
versus the Cubs or something like that
where they can have their tribal values
and have it be in an arena that doesn't
impact the rest of the world
if people are going out and voting like
uh like uh AOC right ocasio-cortez when
she went on Colbert and just made up all
that nonsense about Dred Scott and
Abraham Lincoln it was so laughably bad
I'm like and her vote negates mine worse
though she's in Congress
so we need we we need some kind of look
if you're not interested in politics we
really need to know because you will
make everything worse for everyone else
this is the challenge making sure
everybody has a right to participate but
also making sure they actually want to
right hmm
look when someone posts on Facebook
saying we should ban assault rifles and
then I respond with assault rifles are
regulated under the Hughes Amendment and
they're very difficult to get here's why
and they respond with shut up fascist
you're an idiot I'm like okay you really
don't want to ban assault rifles because
if you did you'd be like tell me how to
do it
so when I I I commented on someone's
profile earlier and I said I think you
mean assault weapons assault rifles are
regulated since 1986. they're actually
very difficult to get it started with
the NFA if you're talking about assault
weapons let's figure out what you're
specifically going for you're talking
about four grips pistol grips things
like that and then you say I don't know
what you're talking about you're dumb
who cares we just need to ban it and I'm
like okay well you're not going to and
you clearly don't care because I didn't
insult them or anything like that their
whole thing is team blue team red and
that's all that matters and then they
have their talking points I you know I I
think like it's glorifying to think
maybe we can remove the idiots from the
process and just have the smart people
do it but like that just is like leads
towards genocide I don't understand how
would we hold people like what would be
the process what we say yeah I was I was
just thinking like like what would be
what would be the criteria for
intelligence are you talking IQ or EQ or
some combination of the two
well I don't think intelligence is a
determinant factor in whether or not you
should be voting it's a question of
whether you actually want to or not so
I'm not saying only the smart people
vote I'm saying you actually have to
walk to the voting booth to vote you
know what I mean like do you really want
to vote or is someone sitting there over
your shoulder saying did you vote for my
guy
so the issue is when you do like
Universal mail-in voting you're going to
have someone sitting there playing video
games and then their roommate or their
mom's gonna come and be like take your
thing and fill it out vote for buying
they go I don't care and like do it now
and go fine whatever
so there there needs to be some degree
of I am choosing to do it needs to be
done to vote so at the very least you
get up you walk to that to the street
and you fill out the form you get rid of
that and you're gonna have a whole lot
of low tier uninterested people being
like whatever you say man I don't care
so like a 10 minute question 50 question
questionnaire kind of thing a lot like
that personality test that Jordan
Peterson does understand yourself
understand I think so I think y'all are
assuming way more than I'm implying I'm
implying like you have to go to the
local voting voting booth to vote like
just just literally go and do it
yourself as opposed to mailing it in
right maybe demonstrate that you have a
stake in the future of the Nation
meaning have families
have practical skills to offer it I mean
you can take it to the next the next
step and make more logical arguments I
mean there's a lot of challenges in
restricting voting rights for sure but
the argument initially was you had to be
a landowner to vote and the left says
wow how offensive because they're basing
today they're basing yesterday off of
today the reason they did it was was
obvious they didn't have IDs how did
they know you actually lived there you
owned a plot of land so you went you
voted then when we entered this hyper
dense Urban you know Society we were
like okay well now there's a lot of
people who do live here and can prove
they live here but don't own the land oh
okay we got to do away with that so then
we're like okay you have to come in and
vote fill out the form you have to
choose to register you have to show up
and you got to do it and I'm like all
those things are good barriers to say
you actually want to vote now that you
you got to be smart I mean it is a
problem when dumb people vote for dumb
things sure but that's representative
democracy or you know how our public
works at the very least though you
should be able to get off your couch
walk a couple blocks and vote I would
love to see people have to live
somewhere for like a year before they
can vote locally that's that that
actually is true in a lot of
jurisdictions oh that's good there's a
residency requirements
the problem is you can move somewhere
didn't uh didn't Andrew Yang try and do
this he got in trouble he was like I'm
gonna move to Georgia and help the
Democrats win and it's like that is so
crooked yeah Matt Walsh did it in
Virginia I think he didn't vote he
didn't vote he did it to speak at a
council meeting because they tried to
keep him out that's different it worked
I mean it's just he he exposed a flaw in
the system in my opinion but he wasn't
he wasn't doing that for politics he was
trying to he was trying to speak about
family and kids at a school and they
changed the rules to Bar him so he
rented a basement Andrew Yang said quite
literally I'm moving there for the
purpose of politics
and then they were like hey that's
illegal that's the problem we have I
mean eliminating mail and voting
entirely would also create a problem for
the Armed Forces for people that are
that are deployed overseas yeah but but
you know you have to State Department
you have to apply for those
you had to so before we did Universal
mail-in voting absentee ballots you
filled out a form they'd mail it to you
you had to do the bare minimum to say I
really want to do this now what do we
get we get Democrat activist knocks on a
door and says that right there fill it
out and they go uh just fill it out
right now put in your mailbox okay fine
whatever what what Biden sure fine and
then boom there you go we're walking
like a line between incentivizing and
disincentivizing voting is that what
this is like you don't want to you want
a little incentivize you want to give
people money you want to slightly
disincentivize voting make it a little
bit annoying like go to the place it's
not even wait in line I mean to be fair
it's not even annoying it's like go vote
is it really that hard to just go and
vote now it should be a holiday in my
opinion yeah that'd be huge and I've
heard Republicans bill that's bad for us
I'm like too effing bad people should
not have to work on voting days and then
they should have to get up and go do it
the alternative is universal mail-in
voting is a disaster it's an absolute
disaster security risks Etc yeah I think
I think I'd be in favor of both those
the combination together have making it
a holiday and making it so that people
have to do something in order to vote
one day no extended no early none of
that absentee voting for people who who
need to do it and you fill it out and
you get it and then voting day is a
holiday you don't gotta work I mean we
have Fourth of July you don't gotta work
done all right so vote vote election day
is a holiday and if you if you'd rather
go to the beach and go party please
please do it that was even an issue for
me in uh 2018 voting in the midterms
when I had just turned 18 I had to skip
school to to do that for like half a day
like I didn't want to do that you didn't
want to skip school no I was a nerd
really and then in college I had to do
uh mail-in vote too because I had
classes then too that's horribly
obnoxious right yeah like who wants to
go through that the service guaranteed
citizenship thing takes it one step
further I mean in Starship Troopers it
was like you had to sign up for some
some kind of community government
service it didn't have to be military
but you had to in some way serve the
community otherwise you didn't get to
vote there's a really good logic behind
that if you're not willing to contribute
to the community why should you get a
say in what the community does only when
it gets dangerous when the community is
like Nazi Germany and they're like
participate in our process or you have
no say particularly in an approved way
only well isn't that isn't that the
premise of Starship Troopers too wasn't
it supposed to be uh like a what's the
word for it classically liberal no no I
mean it's supposed to be mocking fascism
isn't it no no no it was supposed to be
like a a utopian liberal Society
but it was a militant October I mean I
don't know who was it I thought I don't
I don't think that's correct uh any
Utopia the movie the movie apparently I
thought the premise of it was that it
was supposed to be mocking the movie
the so Carl Carl Benjamin might be wrong
Carl Benjamin did a breakdown of this
because he's a huge type of Troopers fan
that the original in the book it was
basically classically liberal that
um you have to provide for your
community otherwise you have no say in
it but uh uh civilians don't get to vote
but they're entitled to all equal rights
you do two years of service in any way
it's not military then you get access to
voting and then in in the actual book I
think it's like the bugs attack Earth
and bomb them in Buenos Aires even in
the movie that's the case but for some
reason the movie tries to make earth out
to be the bad guys even though we were
being attacked by a foreign Invader so I
I I've not swag it was a false it was an
inside job well the bugs in the movie
actually watch him launch the giant rock
it's funny they try to make it seem like
Earth was fascist or something but I've
not I've not read the book I've seen the
movie several times you'll have to watch
Carl Benjamin's breakdown of it okay
yeah he talks about it I just remember I
remember seeing it as a kid and being
absolutely trauma by it what part
um the what's the big like the big brain
thing that would like suck a brains out
which one the brain bug yeah yeah yeah
Starship I like the idea that the humans
are the bad guys I thought that was a
good Twist on the movie I was like Oh I
thought we were fighting evil the whole
time but they attacked us yeah they were
just doing what they do it's like who's
the is this is it this the Scorpion or
the Frog like who's the villain in that
situation scorpion apparently but he's
just doing what scorpions do yeah she's
still a bad guy
I don't know that's bad you know it's
subjective some there there are bad
people who do bad things they're bad
when they do bad things there are that's
it the humans were playing rock music
too loud and it was interfering with the
bugs is that what it was no high
frequency communication yeah and that's
why they throw a rocket who was the
villain yeah oh yeah shut that noise off
yeah all right I guess
I don't know man
you know what
every so often you'll get this period in
pop culture where it's like normal
things are happening and you're like
maybe maybe we're gonna get out of this
one and then something crazy happens
when does that happen it happens
periodically for real I mean it's not
right now at least well no obviously
yeah I think so I when you look at how
blackrock's been exposed on the internet
people are talking about the liberal
economic order now like it's it's been
around for 80 years and they're finally
talking about it that's the opposite of
what we're saying that's good the
exposure is what we need that's not what
we're talking about democracies dies in
silence every so often feels like things
are normal again well that that's when
was the last time that happened like
Marvel movie came out and people started
talking about that or something I mean
well that's happening but the Amber
Heard uh Johnny Depp trial for a little
bit because it was apolitical it was
like people were like celebrities
celebrities I'm like wow celebrities
it's almost like things are normal again
and then all of a sudden Washington Post
was like far right
radicals yeah even that guy twisted
around I I'm feeling what you're saying
here it feels like if some days it feels
like completely normal like this is life
as I know it and then some days I'm like
what in the hell are we gonna do uh am I
I don't feel safe I feel like confused
nervous wreck and then some days it's
like yo I mean it's just like the the
love is coming out of my third of July
felt pretty normal
yeah the weekend for instance not the
Fourth of July
because of Highland Park and
Philadelphia but on the third
it's like relatively calm I mean people
are saying stuff but most people this is
the thing too on holidays you'll really
feel it when people get off the internet
a couple years ago I remember uploading
a video and the viewership was just like
a four like like 40 of what it normally
was and I was like whoa this must be a
bad topic I'm like nobody's watching my
video I wonder if I did something wrong
or whatever but I I know the trick like
sometimes things happen right
we went out to eat every restaurant was
packed with a 20 minute wait
parents with their kids and I went Uh
something's happening the reason why
views were down as I I can't remember
exactly what it was but some like
college got out and everybody I think I
think what it was is really fascinating
it had rained all week and then it was
like it was like Friday till Thursday of
rain and then Thursday was sunny and
like 69 degrees everyone in media was
like I need to go outside
and so nobody's watching yeah this is
the fascinating thing many people on
YouTube don't get they look at their
YouTube views and panic when the views
are bad because they're like oh no my
Channel's dying and then you're like did
it rain when it rains your views go up
when it snows your views go up when it's
sunny your views go down
people don't know that you ever try and
get like a goal a view goal on this
video like I'm gonna get less than 30
000 views on this next video rather than
try and get more which is what
everyone's been trying to do try and get
try and do your best and see if you can
get less because that's more normal I
say don't think about it like when we
first started in the show we were only
getting like a few thousand concurrent
viewers we didn't care we were doing it
because like the I don't know what else
is there to do it's bored you know just
talk about something
so we started talking about stuff and
then we started bringing people out now
here we are just do things that are fun
and keep doing them and get good at it
and then figure it out as you go some
people can't seem to figure it out
that's unfortunate this reality some
people can figure out some people can't
you know figure what out exactly like
how to make a machine grow bigger and
how to turn something into more yeah
right sustainability people have a state
of mind that they need to make things
huge did I succeed if it gets big if I
get the most but size is not what makes
things great it's the ability for the
thing to sustain and adapt so true you
just gotta have fun you got to be
passionate you got to talk about what
you care about and just get started when
I first started my channel it was a
GoPro 4 sitting on top of my monitor and
I'll talk for 10 minutes and then be
like that was it yeah and then I'll put
it up and that's all I would do and then
eventually I was like I got a bunch of
other stories I didn't talk about I'll
just make a couple more videos and then
just started making more and more and
more do you ever make videos directly to
someone nope that's interesting no it
used to be a feature on YouTube that you
could do video replies I took that off I
don't know why because they thought it
was getting underutilized that was how I
made my career on YouTube
the dislike button is getting under you
did Phil DeFranco do that yeah we all
did yeah Phil responded I think he
responded one of my videos way back in
the day but that's how he his first
video was a video response to somebody
huh
all those videos do they still exist on
YouTube uh I saw I just watched his
first his first video response yeah and
it was why Google bought YouTube is
because YouTube was popular because of
the video response the community
basically they called it the community I
mean it was people talking to each other
and it was the most epic epic violation
of the third law of thermodynamics I
don't know what it was but it was like
how is this how are we able to
communicate from all around the world
now in real time and it's always there
for everyone to watch and then Google's
like it's too good we gotta buy it we're
gonna go to super chats if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this Channel and
share the show with your friends tell
them about it we're gonna have a Members
Only After Dark segment coming up at
around 11 p.m tonight so we swear more
we've got some
um some touchy subjects to talk about
it's good fun so go to timcast.com
become a member let's read we got
Juggernaut I'm not reading your first
name because I don't want to have people
emailing me about their kids asking
questions it says I'm listening to Rogan
with Duncan Trussell before the
beginning of this as an atheist they
believe only conserv only concern
derivatives wanted Roe v Wade to be
overturned aside from the fact it's a
moral to terminate life period
so there was a viral clip going around
with Joe and Duncan and they're smoking
and uh I don't know a whole lot about
Duncan Trussell but in this clip I was
like I this is why Joe Rogan's the man
because Joe says Ben Shapiro is a nice
guy he's a good guy you got to talk to
him and Duncan says I don't care and I
was just like whoa that's scary
that you could be wrong
that you could be condemning an innocent
person and you don't care is scary that
was weird too because it was out of
character for Duncan I'm used to Duncan
being very loving and open and he was
like something about that guy man I just
I don't like I don't like him there's
nothing wrong he was saying that like
people are going to exploit Joe
and and try and pull them right and
stuff like that and it's like
people are in a cult man and Joe Rogan
asks questions and that's who he's
always been and he's still very Lefty
and then to hear Duncan be like I don't
care about the truth about a person
they're bad people period that's a scary
over a zealous cult-like mentality he
did in that in that interview if you
watch the entire show which I did is
Duncan eventually was like all right all
right all right I take it back
well that's good that's good yeah and
that's something that you wouldn't see
if they were together in the in the same
room in one space
right like like if if he and and Ben
Shapiro were in the same room I mean
would he actually say that to him would
he actually have that impression or
maybe he would walk in with that
impression and then at the end of an
hour or two hours three hours you know
of sitting and talking and hanging out
that maybe he would have a different
perception by the end of it people
believe crazy stuff like I'll tell you
this Ben Shapiro not short
really yep oh medium-sized uh average
average dude average size dude okay and
but they attack him by saying he's short
and then even people who like him end up
thinking he's short I did and then I met
him and I was like he's like a half inch
shorter than me
well or maybe like an inch shorter or
something it is tough to gauge height on
YouTube
um I so I I told you guys this when
scheduling today but
um I recently got married and I had a
bunch of friends from lawtube come to my
wedding also and it was like the first
time that most of us had met in person
and so that was like one of the funny
things was like figuring out like who's
taller than who and and and one of the
and a lot of them are at least at least
a handful of them the first time that
they actually saw me in person was
literally me walking down the aisle with
my dad and they told me they were like
you're taller than I thought you were
gonna be I'm like well I'm also wearing
heels but yeah I am kind of a tall
person yeah I wonder what that is why
people assume height they didn't I don't
think they assume in the case of Ben
Shapiro they're trying to attack his
masculinity on purpose they're right
they're they're idea is that
conservatives value masculinity
therefore if you emasculate someone
people won't want to listen to it Bill
ottman the CEO founder of Mines when I
first saw him on internet videos on a
YouTube video response that he made to
me I thought he was like five seven he
just seemed like but he's like six two
or something crazy yeah right
also I I thought he was shorter than he
really isn't I mean I haven't actually
seen him in person but
um I mean he's he's also like six two or
six three or I don't know something yeah
so she's tall he's very tall
um but I think part of it sometimes is
the camera angle yes that you have and
and sometimes that can be a factor
cameras above you look small because
people are are imagining they're looking
at you and you must be small yeah all
right let's read some more we got Derek
safer says I simply cannot figure out
how to watch the after show at 11. I am
a member and behind the paywall and I'm
23 so I'm not a technological Boomer
so if you sign up for the website and
you're logged in on the home page every
night around 10 50. we put up it'll be
right there I'll say members only on it
you click it and that's it it plays
um if it's not working then there's an
error send us an email to members
timcast.com but it's really that or if
you click members only we're actually
going to be adding a whole bunch of
shows
the issue is
we're at this point where we have the
money to like start expanding but it's
still hard and we need like a web Editor
to handle all the uploads of graphics
and images and maintaining all this
stuff but it's like it gets more and
more difficult so we need to add more
and more members so what's going to
happen is we're going to create low
budget shows to attract more members and
hope we cross that threshold of spending
less money than you know getting a
little profit off the memberships then
we can hire people to start cleaning
things up and expanding you'll notice
that the daily wires first movies where
either they bought them or they were low
budget like Tara on the Prairie
single location in the middle of nowhere
relatively low low cost to shoot that
kind of stuff do a good story it works
so that's where I work on
um yeah let's read some more
all right
Tyler Brown says no Lydia we Riot that
doesn't run
all right Don Diego says I'm sure of it
now more than ever the planet has
drifted through a cosmic cloud of
stupidity that could not what this is
well we often talk about the Large
Hadron Collider they fired that thing up
today didn't they was it today yeah I
think so yeah maybe let's find out you
hear about this what does it mean all
right so they got this big ring right
it's a magnet and they put particles in
it yeah spin around as fast as possible
and then slam it into something else
they're trying to simulate energy levels
that appeared right after the big bang
so a lot of people were scared that
they'll make black holes and they're
like don't worry the black holes will
dissipate they're too small they can't
sustain themselves and they did this
right before Donald Trump got elected
the first time so the joke is that they
created some kind of dimensional Rift or
something like that and confirmed six
hours ago from Live Science MSN Large
Hadron Collider switches on at highest
ever power level to look for Dark Matter
did anything crazy happen I don't know
yet what are you expecting to happen
though well I think they're looking for
uh excitons and other kind or exitons I
think is how it's pronounced in other
kind of polaratons which are these
subatomic particles that seem to pop in
and out of reality uh maybe when you
bombard plasma with light I'm not
exactly sure the polaraton science is
going to be a big part of the future
what's going to happen is we're all
going to wake up and Hillary Clinton's
gonna be president we're going to be
like what happened the timeline it's
2016 again yeah Gabe H says I love The
Conspiracy Theory episode you guys did
Friday you should look into wendigoon on
YouTube he broke down a rather large
conspiracy theory iceberg in total it's
about nine and a half hours to go to
work wow one of the things we're going
to be doing is we are preparing a weekly
talk show on conspiracy and paranormal I
know we talked about doing this a long
time ago
but uh we ended up with Tales from the
inverted World which is more serial
we're going to be doing a weekly show
and it's going to be exploring deep into
uh conspiracy theories and Unsolved
Mysteries and stuff so that hopefully
will start relatively soon because
that's the plan you just start it up you
slowly build it up but we're currently
renovating our haunted house so that we
can actually do work in it because
there's like asbestos or something I
don't know we'll have to figure that out
but uh hopefully soon within the next
few weeks we're going to have a new
studio facility that's creepy for our
creepy paranormal conspiracy show
that'll be a lot of fun oh some further
info is they're running the the Large
Hadron Collider for four years and then
they're gonna stop it and upgrade it and
then 2029 they're going to start it up
again and expect it to have 10 times
more data cool sideways says Mary has
that half asleep look and I can't get
enough of it like she could be in low-fi
beats to study relax to stream super
cute LOL thank you
I don't know if saying someone looks
like they're half asleep is a good thing
or I mean for them it is so it sounds
like a compliment thank you Cliff the
alien says Taylor Lorenz is originally
from my Planet hence the insect eyes we
didn't like her here glad to see Earth
doesn't either
well all right that's one way to explain
it
I wonder if she ever goes by Tay Lorenz
hello
Joe spinella says Prince changing his
name was a way to maneuver out of his
contract with Warner Brothers so we had
more control over what music he released
when uh and when ultimately
is there another message I don't have
okay I guess that's it we'll have to try
and find the uh it ends there so it was
a way to that's what I thought it was
like a legal thing that's what I heard
that sounds Vaguely Familiar
yeah like how do you enforce a contract
you can't say the word
Beavis McLean says Tim you inspired me
to start building culture after I got to
the military I'll not seek easy money
from Contracting work I'll be making
content to inspire this in future
Generations any advice for a newbie PS
love you and the whole team
um if you're in the military something
military related I don't know start
making videos start small start easy and
just slowly start building up as as it
comes it's not always easy sometimes you
got to get a job you got to invest the
money you're making until you can build
it up to that point
that's how you do it
Inspire those future Generations man
Brian L says name an American colony Ian
we have none
um Wake Island
what's that it's an island in the
Pacific that the U.S conquered in like
1920 or 19 late 1800s yeah like
Philippines was an American colony we do
have territories yeah Puerto Rico Guam
yeah
Puerto Rico Puerto Rico and Guam
apparently there's like no taxes or
something there is that how it works I
think it's supposed to be a tax Haven I
think yeah yeah but they but they also
have no voting rights right taxation
without representation so it's like you
can set a business there so I'm kind of
like wow we should
run Tim cast there tax-free USA
yeah but I'm getting people out there
stuff mortem isn't edgy says hey Tim and
crew I'm in high school and I found your
show in March of 2020 my freshman year
I've been a loyal Spotify listener ever
since thanks so much for giving me a
dissenting voice from my peers vapid
left us trash my first Super Chat hey
really appreciate it man
glad to hear it
all right
what is this
Tyler Adams says I think when you
referenced smilebots from Doctor oh
smile boss that's right from Dr earlier
today did you like that series if so
does it hold up to Star Trek and theme I
feel like the episode haven't sent his
best Doctor Who episode I haven't seen a
whole lot of Doctor Who but there was an
episode where they go to this planet
where there's like a colony
but there's no humans and they find
robots with big smiley faces on them and
they wear badges with like smiley face
or something like that and then the
general idea is unhappiness is a virus
is a theme sort of so the robots were
tasked with keeping everyone happy but
one day someone died of old age
everyone around the old woman got sad
the machines couldn't figure out how to
make them happy because you can people
get sad when the people who were sad
came into contact with happy people and
explained someone died the happy people
became sad
so the robots were like we can't stop
the unhappiness and it spreads so they
killed anyone who was unhappy oh geez
well that resulted in everyone else
getting very unhappy so they end up
killing everybody so like Doctor Who and
you know the other person have to walk
around faking a smile like everything's
good
yeah it's creepy but that's what people
don't understand about AI it doesn't go
the way you think it's going to go you
know
Rodolfo Ramirez says we are in the
corporate version of the movie
Nightcrawler have you guys seen
Nightcrawler I haven't no yeah Jake
Gyllenhaal yes not the superhero
Nightcrawler but it's no he's a late
night photographer or a journalist that
like chases tragedy basically in the
middle of the night and like
nightcrawlers our Journal reporters who
go out at night and chase after crime
scenes and accidents and then sell the
footage to news outlets
yo this movie's so good is it really
it's really good you got an interesting
look at the psychology of people that
seek trauma and it's it's an indictment
of journalists you don't like
journalists watch the movie Nightcrawler
you're gonna be like yup it's brutal
he's an evil dude really yes and the J
and and the other people the news
outlets also very evil it's it's amazing
I don't want to spoil it but he's an
evil dude and the people in the news
outlets are like good they're like that
we don't care the ratings the ratings
it's just it's brutal yeah man very very
brutal
all right let's read it what do we got
here oh storm Viking says Ian you
disgust me sometimes with communist woke
talking points America was not founded
as a slave state learn history and if
you hate America so much move out Canada
sounds right up your alley oh that was
brutal it was also kind of vague I
thought the U.S did have slaves when it
was founded and right before it
says Ian's rolling 20s cast IRL that is
the wonderful dichotomy of reality I'll
see you in the chats I'll be like 20 Ian
one Ian Sean St George says I'm a little
surprised daily wire dead naming you on
Twitter isn't the lead JK so I tweeted
the reason people call me Pim tool all
the time is because it's my dead name
therefore if you call me Pimp tool I
will report you and I'm it's a gag and
then the daily wire account called me
pimp tool I thought it was funny but
that's the game we can play right you
can't call me any names anymore is that
how it works think about how insane this
is if if you call someone
um
what's communist for instance what if
someone in the comment called me
communist should I go after that guy
that's insane on Twitter if you call
someone a butt head it's a direct insult
let's say you call them like a mother
effort or something totally allowed but
if you use the incorrect name your band
that's so weird
yeah it's arbitrary did you know this
through Twitter allows you to remove
videos with you in them whether you own
the copyright or not
so if like Ian if you're walking down
the street and someone films you and
then uploads it you can get it removed I
think Twitter admins are too involved in
the process at this point they should
the software should just be there and
they should be like making sure that
people aren't destroying the world I'm
not so sure about that either though
because
Tick Tock seems to be run by robots and
they ban everyone yeah I got we got IRL
got banned from Tick Tock I don't I just
don't think that that was like one
person's decision
it's the algorithm because you got Mass
reported you don't think it lied at the
feet of the chairman
chairman uh what's his name Xi Jinping
at the top of the Communist Chinese
oh we can talk about whatever you want
Raymond g says I love that the UFO is
always spinning
Tim gave a nice spin before the show
tonight just keeps going all right
Brandon Tom says imagine if Biden went
on The Joe Rogan Experience hey Jamie
can you check batacav care here's the
thing
Joe Rogan was like I don't want Trump
coming the show because it would help
him okay Joe would you have Biden on the
show it'll hurt him hands down fact Joe
Biden for two hours in that chair with
Joe would Biden would be destroyed
I mean he did offer it to to moderate a
debate between the two of them for 2020.
but can I just go back to that point I
made during that segment
if Joe Rogan thinks Trump coming on a
show would benefit him
and he thinks Joe Biden is a dead man as
he said it
he's basically saying how he views both
individuals sure Trump is capable either
of lying or convincing you and Biden is
is out of it so
he shouldn't have either of them having
Biden on a show would help Trump
tremendously
all right
Adam Townsend said for proper proper
context you can see Rogan's quote on Lex
Friedman's recent interview I recommend
you actually watch the whole show
because you know
you get the full context oh did you
watch it earlier I watched a big chunk
of it me too
I don't I didn't watch the whole thing I
watched the relevant political part it's
because on YouTube you can actually jump
to that it's funny because it was like
just two dudes talking I was like oh I
can't wait to go listen to two guys talk
like what what is society what it like
we really are social creatures that that
was that invigorating to hear two random
guys have a conversation
all right the KL tanker says California
is passing a bill that would require a
homeowner renter or gun gun insurance
policy in your name to own a gun
essentially making you pay for your
rights and Maryland just announced that
they're getting rid of the qualification
for a handgun license
so this is really funny Supreme Court
said you can't require a reason for
getting a permit New York lost New York
immediately came out nullified Supreme
Court's rulings and we're gonna do it
everyone anyway Maryland came out and
they're like okay from this point
forward remove the qualifying reason for
all handgun permits and I was like okay
all right let me look up what you need
to get a Maryland uh handgun permit
yo it's still impossible you need to do
I think 16 hours of handgun training
which is probably going to be at what
four days unless you do an eight hour
course followed by Saturday and Sunday
some people maybe you'll do that
you have to pass a proficiency test
I get it
but saying someone lacks skills
means they don't get their rights is
kind of a crazy idea like I understand
why you're like you have to know how to
use open before you get a permit for it
but the Constitution says shall not be
infringed there's no qualifications you
can't do that I'm surprised Maryland
hasn't been sued over that you have to
get uh 25 for a non-non law enforcement
or security you have to seven you have
to hit uh 25 rounds if you you have to
get 70 accuracy with 25 rounds from 15
yards
not like the hardest thing in the world
requires some some practice and some
training but I just thought it was kind
of crazy that they could put a a skill
requirement on it what if you're
what if um you know your hands busted up
like what if your hands are broken and
you're like someone's trying to kill me
but I broke my hands
I could use it if I had to but I'm not
going to be able to be that accurate
like well you you don't get your rights
because you're not good enough to use it
it's kind of a crazy idea right
legally blind then they just are not
allowed to have a gun I mean obviously
you would think it wouldn't necessarily
blind people have guns I think they are
they are
you like Imagine This
I'm going to say it right now blind
people should be allowed to walk in and
buy a gun and bullets and walk out
period And I would love for all of the
Liberals to come out and tell me that
someone due to their Disability should
be denied a human right
say it because I'll take that clip by
all means do it
just because you're blind doesn't mean
you don't get the right to have to bear
or type up and you know why because
maybe you have someone who's who's there
to a caretaker
maybe you have someone who looks after
you and you want to get a weapon for
yourself they're not going to carry it
around but other people can pick up a
weapon and defense of others
tell me that people don't deserve their
rights if they're disabled I call you
nuts
Blackwing says you are partially right
about the media thinking they know
everything they do get experts experts
that will tow the media line for a price
that's absolutely correct they'll bring
people in and say we'll give you the
money just say what we want you to say
Z Meister says as a member please refer
to the Covington kid as cuff cath kid I
cringe every time you say that as a
graduate from Covington Catholic
okay you want me to be a little bit more
specific we'll call it cuff cath the
problem is I don't think anyone knows
what that means so you went there you
know that most people don't know what
Cove cath would be and I have to explain
it further I could say Covington
Catholic that's for sure
Eric Boyd says as a daily wire
subscriber hearing you congratulate them
I had to subscribe to timcast too I did
and here's some Super Chat money too
let's let's catch daily wire and beat
them in creating culture that's what I'm
saying thank you very much Eric no I'm a
huge fan of what they're doing I am
jealous of what they're doing we're uh
we've got something in the in the works
we're planning something special as a um
homage to the Daily wire and uh We're
not gonna say what it is until it's
ready to come out and it's going to be
really fun and really funny but uh
they're they're absolutely killing it
doing the Lord's work they're making
movies that are just movies they're
standing up for Freedom they're standing
up for this country so their Victory is
our Victory you know what you know why I
do all of this why I do this show it's
because I'm tired of the lies I want to
call out the media the Liars the
manipulators
when the daily wire does that in Spades
it's just good news across the board
so let's see let's see more Victory you
know what I'd love to see you get
Stephen Crowder you get Tim cast you get
daily wire who are some other you get
Carl Benjamin count dankula you get all
these people massive success hundreds of
millions of viewers CNN just
I mean it's already happened CNN's
failing daily wires taken off these are
good days man this is these are good
days
all right yellow fluffy feather says
Luke come back we promised Tim will let
you speak your mind and not be mean to
you
uh yeah Luke what are you doing did you
bully Luke off the show yeah did you see
yeah yeah that's right it was Sheamus
actually they were nose to nose well
Sheamus and Luke were always fighting
and then Luke was like I'm not here if
Sheamus here and he left and then James
like I'm gonna hear from Luke's here and
he left now they're both gone neither of
them are here that's what happens when
you stick to what you say you're gonna
do that's actually not refusal to adapt
no I was just kidding uh Luke is um what
is he doing some hippie stuff up in New
Hampshire I think yeah he's returned his
eminent that's for sure yeah he'll be
back soon but um
crazy stuff going on so I'll shout out
I'm going to shout out uh Mercedes-Benz
because we had a vehicle for picking up
guests so when we have people fly in we
have someone go and pick them up and
bring them here it's actually cheaper
than getting a car service for sure and
um here's the story as I was told
we had an oil issue brought it to
Mercedes-Benz in Hagerstown Maryland and
there's a reason this story is a point
rather than we're talking about just
bear with me and uh they said they fixed
it we were then driving one day and the
engine seized and the engine just became
trash twenty thousand dollars to fix so
we brought it to a different
Mercedes-Benz this time in Chantilly
Virginia
and uh then when we got it back the
suspension was broken right away like we
get it back we're like hey what's wrong
with it and they went oops we'll fix it
then they call us apparently or message
us saying oh also the engine mounts are
broken and it's like what is going on
with these dealerships not only they
won't answer their phones totally broken
so what we think is happening is
nobody's working and their supply chain
disruptions so they just can't fix and
so I feel like they're lying to us just
to get us out the door because they
can't fix the problems I have no idea
but this is one of the big issues with
Luke is that everyone is is feeling this
car repairs are getting more and more
difficult that's for sure and if that's
the case it's meaning it means
everything's going to take a lot longer
we've been trying to build the new HQ in
West Virginia and it's been delayed by
like three months just because of all
the supply disruptions so
but uh Mercedes-Benz you are trash and I
am extremely livid I tweeted about it
because after like what has it been six
months
three to six months of trying to get
this vehicle fixed we had to wait to buy
a new vehicle and it's funny because
people on Twitter like Tim you're rich
who cares I'm like yo this is the
businesses vehicle employees can't use
our personal vehicles the business needs
a car to pick up guests to do the show
and Mercedes in my opinion I believe
they broke the engine I believe they
screwed up they broke it and now the
only way I can get it resolved is by
coming on the show and saying
Mercedes-Benz is trash don't buy their
cars
that's it that's all I can do it's going
to cost us like fifty thousand dollars
and it's like what can you do about it
wow that's like a new car twenty
thousand dollars because the engine bro
the time is expensive for a business to
lose its transport when the engine
seized and everything else is good it's
like spend the 20 now and the car works
I wonder if we live in an age of
entitlement where I'm like you should do
my thing for me where's my where's my
easy things like I'm so used to things
being relatively fluid and easy that now
it's like Harvest your own grain bro
like come on well we did that yeah we
did yeah we had some weed to do it again
too all right David C says reach please
reach out to Matt Christensen and blonde
we need this mashup love you guys
absolutely would love to have both of
them on the show that'd be great
we will bring them out
Bachi points has anyone else think Gavin
Newsom looks and acts like Christian
Bale in American Psycho
yes agreed he's not like
yeah
I bet he loves that movie
I'm gonna be just like Patrick Bateman
Brandon de Arma says Hey first time
super chatting also not even a question
uh related tonight I'm putting this in
at work because I've been wondering what
y'all think of the game death stranding
the director's cut game came out a while
back oddly relevant currently I never
played it did you play it no never did
it didn't really appeal to me it's not
my kind of game it's a it's a game where
you run the whole game is like running I
heard it on your back I heard the game
is called is um carry all the groceries
into the house in one trip simulator yes
that's what people told me don't pass
out simulator from all the way it's the
guy from Walking Dead what's his name
and you just carry stuff Daryl from
Walking Dead yeah and you just you're
carrying like a child in a case keep
it's like the last baby or something you
got to get it to the city no it's
something like the babies keep away the
demons or something like that okay I'm
sure people are chatting like you guys
have no idea it's like don't don't let
me know how much to the right don't lean
too much to the left it's not my kind of
game gaffes says Tim your brother's
Channel reactor is legendary
oh yes can we talk about that the
legendary the legend I just want to talk
about no you're not allowed
it's dead naming
all right Kate J says Tim this just
broke today a judge in Uruguay or it's
Uruguay for those Americans orders
government and Pfizer present all
information on covid-19 Jabs within 48
hours including the presence the
possible presence of graphene oxide and
nanotech
just because they're requesting it
doesn't mean it's there so we'll see if
anything comes out of that but you know
I'd be I'd be shocked if any any stuff
come out of that like if any of that
came out to be true to be honest
all right Stephen uh Simard says it's
100 the supply chain right now I'm a
mechanic and I have had eight plus month
wait times for parts it's unreal wow wow
that's insane Kaylee and Shaw indie game
says death stranding is one thousand
percent Ian's kind of thing it seems so
boring Like You Gotta Give no action you
gotta give it a try is there at least a
storyline to it yeah it is a story yeah
it's basically like it's like a movie
but you have a little bit of control
over which direction the guy leans okay
ladies and gentlemen if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends tell them
about if you really want to help and
head over to timcast.com become a member
because we are expanding and we need
your support to start doing more shows
one thing we really want to do is we
need a web editor so that we can clean
up all the graphics on the site right
now the website uses a YouTube API to
pull images but they're low res so we
need to really fix that stuff up we need
to hire somebody and uh it's tough you
gotta hire people then you gotta fun
shows and shows are expensive but want
to do more we're gonna members only show
coming up at about 11 pm check that out
and follow the show at timcast IRL on
Instagram WE Post clips and you can
follow me at timcast Alita do you want
to shout anything out
um well you can go to my channel uh
legal bytes on YouTube I'm also on
Twitter Instagram Facebook
locals and patreon right on yeah cool um
and I also have a gift that I wanted to
give oh a gift um but if you want I can
I can give it to you in the members only
stream let's do that okay okay find out
what the mystery gift is
gonna be a rock
everyone's gonna sign up to see what it
is a rock no it's it's but it's better
than a rock it's it's a little bit it's
a little bit more tailored is it a gun
no I don't think I don't think I don't I
don't think TSA would allow me to a
plane with that all right uh you can
find me on Instagram or WeChat at closer
Kitty or you can join us uh we're live
at 3 P.M eastern time and noon Pacific
time at Pop Culture crisis on YouTube
come join us tomorrow
you can also follow me Ian crossland.net
if you want to know what kind of games I
do like it's like turn-based strategy
games like slave Aspire civilization
that kind of stuff Crusader Kings that
one's awesome the second one and the hot
action games like mobas like uh some of
them I don't know list goes on I've got
like uh 1500 games on I don't know I
have so many games whenever I play
Civilization I start building up my
civilization and I just mind my own
business yeah flourishing and developing
technology and then some a-hole is like
I'm going to invade and then I'm like
now I have to destroy your siblings the
entire level it to the ground it's
exhilarating yeah just wipe them out I
don't even take the city you attacked me
over the ground yeah and then I launched
a spaceship all right bye everyone we
also have Chris pressing buttons I don't
know if you wanted to shout anything out
uh hi yeah not really all right you're
the reactor Chris's channel that was my
reaction YouTube reactor all right
everybody we will see you all over at
timcast.com thanks for hanging out